[inaudible],
we're back world,
I used to say America,
but foreign people get upset for
bastards living in other countries.
Sad enough.
It can't be grace on our patch of dirt.
Uh,
I just had to explained to Cameron Hanes
that when your iphone,
when you use a bunch of Apps,
you double click on that bottom button
and then you,
it shows you all the apps that are
running in the background.
Most people don't know this.
Most people just use their phone.
Right?
But that's a fucking resource,
Robert,
right there,
buddy.
You gotta.
Be careful.
I learned something today.
I got to have to show people things.
Now when I'm showing you tech tips,
you know,
you know your tech retarded.
I'm a little bit behind the curve.
So what's happening brother?
How you feeling,
man?
You just ran 100 miles a week ago.
Yeah,
I did.
It was,
it was about a week ago,
right?
It was,
yeah,
it was last Saturday and Sunday.
So father's Day.
All in preparation for a 200 mile run in
August.
That's right.
God Damn Dude.
Yeah.
We're talking about today,
like the mental games that your brain
starts playing on you.
Yeah.
And you were describing all the shit
that your brain starts doing to you
while you're running.
Yeah.
I always.
There's so many peaks and valleys when
you push yourself like that and it's uh,
you know,
I was thinking about all the ways I
could quit,
how I could come up with an excuse to
get out of this race and really I could
come,
I could say anything because who's gonna
who's gonna ever questioned it because
it's like,
okay,
how many people have ever run for 24
straight hours.
Right?
So you can,
you can't really question me,
but it's just I pushed myself.
So I mean I couldn't live with myself if
I quit the race,
but I'm not saying I wasn't thinking
about how nice it would have been
stopped running.
Well,
anytime you're working out,
I mean if you just think about a yoga
class,
which is only 90 minutes.
Yeah,
those last 20 minutes you totally
thinking about,
it'd be so nice to just get the fuck out
of this hot room.
Drinks cold water.
But you just power through now.
Multiply that times 24.
Yeah.
And way harder.
Yeah,
because you're running,
you're exhausted,
you're in pain.
I can't even imagine I'm saying all
these things and I'm just guessing.
It's like,
well,
it's,
you know,
I,
I teamed up with a pretty good runner,
Jo Johann to start the race.
He was getting a workout in.
Um,
he was pacing at the western states 100,
which was this last weekend.
And um,
so he,
he wanted to get a good workout,
so I was like,
oh cool,
I can knock off a bunch of miles with
him.
So we were running pretty fast pretty
fast for,
you know,
when you have to run for 24 straight
hours.
But we knocked off 10 miles quickly.
I remember I was running with him,
as you know,
after you run 10 miles,
you know,
you've done something and I'm thinking
to myself,
I got 19 more miles.
I felt like I had already got a pretty
good workout and I hadn't even got
started.
Really felt like you were done and you
had 90 miles left.
Yeah.
So it's uh,
it's,
you know,
you talk about mental strength and just
keeping,
keep hammering.
Yeah,
exactly.
He just had to keep hammering daunting
[inaudible].
And what is it like when it's over?
What is the feeling like when you cross,
when it's 24 hours at times up,
you look at your,
your distance,
102 miles.
What does that feel like?
It feels good most days,
and this is just me,
I can't expect anybody to be able to
relate to my screwed up mine,
but I mean me personally,
I can go run 15 miles,
get a good workout,
go home and an hour later I'm thinking I
could have done more.
I'm not satisfied.
So the big thing for me is when I've
done something like that for the one of
the few times throughout the year,
I feel satisfied that I gave what I had.
Wow.
So it's just so brutal that you never
feel like you could have done more.
No,
no,
no.
I always think I could have been more.
No,
I'm disappointed with myself.
Uh,
um,
just because in that race,
and I can,
I can try to have it make sense.
Um,
I can be logical about it and I could
say,
well I went out really fast because I
want it to be as miserable as possible
for as long as possible to prepare
myself for the big foot 200.
So I can say,
well I ran super hard for,
for hours hoping I was going to be
miserable for 20 and I knew my pace that
would,
would have been a,
would be slower and it'd be more painful
but in the big picture to help me.
Um,
but that's just words to me.
I'm thinking I had a,
I was in first place through 50 miles.
I was,
you know,
did 50 miles and in eight hours.
And so I was on pace for a lot of miles,
a second place at a 62 miles and I was
at 12 hours.
I had run,
I think 65 miles.
So I'm on pace for 130,
so I really died.
And Yeah,
you,
I can,
I can use words and say,
well,
is it,
it was a plan,
it was,
it was part of being miserable and
preparing myself for a greater
challenge,
but I also feel like,
you know,
I gave up,
I'm miles and I could gotten my most
miles ever and I should have got 120
plus miles.
And so yeah,
there's always the feeling I could have
done more even even though.
But I'm a little bit satisfied
now.
We're at the end of it.
So you're,
you're,
you're killing it at 50 miles.
You're in first place.
And then is it just simply a matter of
you just muscle fatigue and pain and
you're just saying for me can only push
so far?
Yeah,
I can't speak for anybody else probably
for some people it's fatigue.
Some people it's a just mental
exhaustion.
Um,
for me it's pain,
it's just I've run and I did my first
marathon in 2002,
so I've been doing this for whatever,
14 years.
Um,
multiple marathons every year back to
back.
Sometimes my body is not 100 percent,
so I can push,
I have a high pain tolerance,
but eventually,
um,
it adds up and so it's pain for me.
Is this a joint pain,
knees,
everything.
Is it just the whole body?
It's waste down,
hips,
knees,
ankles,
feet.
And how long does it take you to
recover?
Like you were telling me that your legs
are swollen.
Twice the size of normal.
Yeah.
Last year.
Last year was way worse.
This year I had,
I've put in a bunch of miles leading up.
I was running about a half a marathon a
day,
so my body was,
is pretty fit and pretty used to it.
So my recovery was much shorter.
I mean I,
and again,
people aren't going to understand this,
but the next day after I ran 102 I ran
13 miles and that was just because when
I run the big foot 200,
I'm going to have to be able to come
back after,
you know,
multiple days of being hurt and banged
up.
And that's the name of the game,
you know,
to cover 200 miles in a couple days,
like I want to,
I'm not going to be a hundred percent.
So I thought well I can't,
I can't know what it feels like to run
after I run 100 miles and less one.
I run a hundred miles and two,
I run the day after.
So you can't simulate that.
There's no way to simulate that.
So you ran 13 miles a day after you run
100,
two miles.
And what the fuck is that like a,
it'd be using the term loosely.
It was painful.
Slow.
I was hiking the uphills running would
be like,
it would,
I probably looked like a 90 year old man
trying to run it.
Fricken hurt.
And what are you legs?
Totally swollen.
What you doing this?
Yeah.
[inaudible].
My uh,
my ankles are swollen and calves that
don't really have an ankle.
It's the same size for my foot up.
And I mean it's not good for me.
I mean it's not in anybody who talks
about doing hundreds.
Hundreds aren't good for anybody.
So it's,
it's.
Yeah.
I know that what I do isn't in the best
interest of my body,
but it's just the name of the game is
what I do,
so what you do is not in the best
interest of your body.
You understand this,
you're very aware of this and you're a
professional bowhunter essentially,
but you have this thing in your head
where you have to push yourself as far
and as hard as possible to find out for
yourself to set goals,
to try to push past this pain and
endurance barrier that you have.
Is that what it all is?
I'm just trying to make sense of it
because it's not like you're getting
paid to do these.
No,
these are amateur race now.
Not Getting at all.
This
is just for me.
I used to think I was an idiot for
competing in martial arts matches for no
money.
Yeah.
You know,
but this is.
This is crazy.
Like you're.
You're doing this at 48 years old with a
family with a job.
Yeah.
And you're still.
It's just,
it's just,
it's just what I feel like I need to do
and I don't.
I don't,
you know,
don't know how long you're going to
continue to do this.
No,
but uh,
you know,
that people have told me when I started
doing marathons and running the mountain
back home,
like I said,
I don't know,
years ago,
15 years ago,
and people said then,
well,
if you keep running like this by the
time you're 40,
you won't be able to run.
And so here I am.
They always say that.
Yeah,
I know.
So I just,
the point to point to that is I don't
really care.
I don't do it for anybody.
I don't do what I do for anybody else.
Just for me.
I feel like I need to do this.
I like pushing my limits.
That's why,
you know,
if I would have listened to people
telling me what I shouldn't do or
couldn't do or nobody could do,
I wouldn't have done hardly anything in
my life.
So the point is I don't care.
I don't care what anybody says,
I don't care what anybody thinks.
I just,
this is what I do.
I need to do it.
I like finding my absolute limit and
seeing how much I can withstand and this
is us offices.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing that people always
do.
They have you do that.
It's going to kill you if you have debt.
It's going to break it down.
What are you doing?
Lifting weights.
You know,
I've heard the people that lift weights
actually live shorter lives,
right?
There's always this,
these people that want to tell you to
not do that.
You know,
like I'm always like,
why are you doing it?
But I'm never going to tell you don't do
it.
I just don't understand that there's,
there's something to that mentality that
we're kind of talking about this earlier
today.
I think there's something in some people
when they see someone doing something
crazy that they can't do and they want
to figure out there's got to be
something wrong with you and they've got
to figure out a way to criticize you
instead of saying,
wow,
that guy's fucking crazy.
Or Wow,
that's a crazy commitment.
I,
I don't want to do it,
but I respect,
appreciate it.
Instead of doing that,
they try to like poke holes that may or
may not even be there.
They try to.
You're kind of admitting that it's not
good for you,
not kind of your 100 percent admitting
for you.
It's not,
but it is good for you in one way you're
like your mind desires this extreme
challenge and that keeps you very calm
and sane.
See as your.
You're the kind of guy where I feel like
if that didn't exist you would have like
real problems,
like just integrating and relating to
regular society probably.
I mean that's,
I dunno,
I dunno what I would be like without the
challenge that I take on if I,
but part of me feels like if I didn't do
it,
I would be a shell of myself as far as
I wouldn't be living up to my ability.
My whole thing is like if I'm able to do
it,
I need to attempt it.
I need to try.
I need to do it.
I mean because I just think that people
need to live up to their full potential.
That's what I'm doing.
Is there anything else though that you
think is interesting like in that way,
like this is,
it's a competitive thing in some ways,
like because you were saying,
you know,
hey,
I'm first place at 50 miles,
but at some,
somewhere along the line it becomes
more,
you're pushing yourself and it becomes
less of you in.
You're not really engaging with someone
else,
even if you're racing them,
you really kind of all in your own mind.
Right?
Is that.
Yeah,
it's uh,
yeah,
look,
I look at it more of just a competition
with myself than with another race or,
or,
or another person.
Of course if I'm running it would be
cool to be first,
you know,
I mean that's just,
I'm a competitive person.
There's no doubt.
But what I do,
my workouts are always by myself.
I'm,
nobody's pushing me.
It's just me and setting the goals,
like to run big foot $200 or whatever.
That's just me,
you know,
I don't know if anybody,
I might not even see anybody during that
whole race.
So it was just like,
you know,
I think there's 75 or so people signed
up,
but it's going to be probably pretty
spread out pretty quickly just depending
on how fast people go out or do whatever
over 200 miles point to point.
So I could go,
you know,
to complete days and not see anybody.
So yeah,
it's,
it's not,
it's not really,
it's not like the Olympic 100 meter dash
where you're lined up against,
you know,
eight other guys and you see exactly
where everybody is at.
It's,
this is more about a test of a personal
will.
So,
you know,
we were talking today also,
we're a guy that we know who's a kind of
an expert and a lot of physical things
are saying,
well why don't you,
uh,
take epo,
all these people that you're racing
against,
you'd probably take an epo.
It's not like they're going to test you,
but you're like,
well,
[inaudible] probably not going to help
me with pain.
No,
I don't really know what EPA does,
but all I know is what,
what limits me is just that pain.
So unless something can like make me
mentally stronger,
I don't know if it's gonna help and uh,
and a race like that because it's not
like you're going super fast,
you know,
it's not like the pace is extraordinary.
It's just grinding.
Those ultra marathon guys are seeking
help with edible marijuana.
That's a big one lately.
And apparently it's a big with a lot of
these ultra marathon guys were just
reduces inflammation in some way that
they find very beneficial as opposed to
nonsteroidal anti inflammatories,
which we'll probably get into to.
It was talking about that because the
Rhonda Patrick thing,
but these ultra marathon guys,
you know,
now that it's becoming more and more
acceptable to use cannabis as people are
coming out and talking about it's,
you know,
it's uh,
it's interesting that it benefits them
in that way because a Jujitsu people
have been saying it for years that,
uh,
people always associate marijuana with
you being lazy.
But with a lot of Jujitsu guys,
they find that it makes them more
creative and more tuned into what
they're doing.
And also able to.
Jujitsu can be pretty painful too.
But although it's a different kind of
pain,
it's pain in,
in short,
short exchanges or painful that you
don't want to tap and you fight your way
out of a choke or something like that.
But the grinding monotonous pain of what
you're doing is kind of a different kind
of pain.
If I talk about what it would be like,
I'm just talking out of my ass.
Yeah.
Well here's what I.
here's what I will say.
If somebody would offer me some edible
cannabis at mile 80 last weekend you had
taken it,
I would.
I would have done almost anything to
make the pain stop.
But
I have a regular job.
I get surprised.
Drug tests at work so often they
surprised drug does to a god.
I don't even,
I don't know.
Probably.
Once a year.
And what are they testing for?
I don't know.
Just they just want your pee pee man.
Yeah.
I don't know what they do,
but I mean I'm not.
You know,
there's something fucked up about that
because it's one thing if you were doing
a terrible job like yeah,
like say if you were like a a guy who
handles heavy machinery,
you keep cutting off people's fingers
like,
Hey,
maybe we should test camp a fuck.
Is he up to camps high as fuck?
It's not that.
It's just they just decided like even if
your job,
if you're doing your job well,
they still feel like they can test your
body and find out what you're doing and
it's also one of the real problems is
it's rooted in ignorance because if
you're,
if you have this stuff in your system,
like say if you smoke pot on a Friday,
you get off work,
have a joint,
go play baseball with your son,
have a good time.
It's not like you're high on Monday when
you show up for it,
but it'll still be in your system.
Yeah.
So they're,
they're making sure you're not doing
anything that they don't like when
you're not there.
I don't know that part of it.
I don't really care personally because I
live a clean life.
I mean,
I don't drink,
don't smoke,
don't do whatever.
I mean,
so they can test whatever,
but I think part of it is uh,
um,
it's,
it's one of the best places to work in
the area.
So they figured that,
you know,
part of the stipulation of working here
is you're subjected to these drug tests.
If you don't like it,
you don't have to work here.
Right.
So,
oh,
I get it.
I mean it's,
I get,
and I'm not saying that they're probably
not testing for pot and thinking or I'm
sure they are testing for pot,
but I mean it's,
you know,
I think they test for alcohol.
I think metric test for alcohol,
I think they do.
You have to be drunk there.
Well,
you'd have to be drunk out of a job.
You don't have to have a drink at lunch
and then they keep up
to do that.
That's,
I'm not saying people do that,
but they could.
But you could get hammered on Friday and
Monday be clean as a whistle.
Right?
Yeah.
That when they always do it is they'll
call like it.
You know,
I start work at seven,
so it'd be like 7:15 he needed,
he needed to be to wherever and 15
minutes.
So I think it's just they don't want
somebody out hammered drunk at three in
the morning.
I'd probably still show up there at
7:30.
Right,
totally makes sense.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense because yeah,
you are compromised and even if you show
up and you're stoned at work for a lot
of people that are compromised,
I understand the idea that you would
want someone to not have a drug problem.
Right?
Because we all know people that have had
problems for me,
like the most disturbing one has been
people that I know that a big pill
problems like speed and things along
those lines because a lot of the times
they're functional but just a little
off.
And if you're dealing with important
stuff,
right,
you could be making critical decision
errors and because you're impaired.
Yeah.
So they might have hired you based on
your critical thinking and your
reasoning,
but then that's all being compromised by
a drug and there's only one way to find
out what the fuck is going on with you
testing.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
The problem with the cannabis things to
twofold.
One,
it stays in your system.
Your you can test for it for weeks and
weeks after it's psychoactive because
it's fat soluble and two,
because this assumption that if you use
something you abuse something is not,
it's not accurate and it's only applies
to losers.
So like if you say,
well look at all these losers,
they get high every day.
Well yeah.
Okay.
But there are also losers.
Yeah,
there's a lot of responsible people.
But when I say losers,
I don't mean if you get high every day,
you're a loser.
I know people that get high every day
and they're super successful.
Businessman it guys.
I know a lot of people,
I know people that micro dose Lsd all
the time and they run multimillion
dollar businesses and they do it all the
time.
Yeah.
But their personality is such that
recreationally,
they don't have an issue,
they can do things and doesn't overwhelm
their life,
but some people can't gamble.
You know what I mean?
Some people,
like if you play poker with some people,
they'll lose their fucking mind.
Next thing you know,
they're on a flight to vegas.
They're going crazy and they lost their
mortgage is a disease.
It's a legitimate mental disease,
but not in the sense that you catch it.
You know,
Oh man,
I didn't wash my hands.
I caught Vegas.
You know,
it's not like that.
But it's a legitimate disease in the
sense that it can fuck with your mind in
a way that is almost out of your
control.
Like a cold makes your physical health
out of your control.
Like when I have a cold,
I get upset at myself because I'm like,
you fucking dummy.
You let yourself get rundown or I know
you didn't get enough sleep.
You didn't,
you know,
whatever it is.
You traveled too much and here you are.
Now you feel like,
shit,
this is stupid.
Yeah,
well that's the sort of the same thing
that happens people when they get a
gambling addiction,
so it's not a substance thing.
It's not like saying,
hey,
you know,
cam,
we're going to test you for gambling.
Did you,
uh,
when you play poker with your buddies
over the weekend,
how much did you gamble?
Oh,
10 bucks.
Too much.
You know,
you can't,
you can't do that to people.
You can't.
I think there's a,
there's a real problem with that and you
know,
I mean,
I guess you could say if you,
if it's your,
you're the employer and you know,
this is the kind of people that you
want.
It's up to you.
I don't,
I don't fucking buy that.
Yeah,
I don't buy that.
I say if the guy's doing a good job,
there should be no issues.
Right?
Well,
I think,
uh,
and I think there are a fair employer.
So I think even if you did test for
something,
um,
and you were that good employee,
they're gonna,
you know,
they're going to work through whatever
issues you're going to make.
You go to Rehab,
but a bunch of losers maybe in sit
around talking about pot.
You imagine what it's like going to a
rehab.
If you smoke a little weed and you get
popped at work and you got to go to a
rehab with a bunch of stone cold
junkies,
they're all covered in scabs,
clonic,
fake spiders all day and or ultra
marathon runners
were talking about that.
Test me after the big foot.
200 places.
I'm going to get you so mad.
I'm going to get you a ton of it.
I take a couple months off work after
that.
I'm going to um,
there was a pre workout supplement that
we were talking about on the way up here
to where they pulled it off the shelf
because they found fucking meth in it.
Straight up meth.
It's like a meth,
like substance that had never been
tested on human beings and pull this
shit off the shelves.
I asked Joe what it was called
[inaudible].
You know that stuff would work
right?
That stuff.
People get super addicted to that
though,
you know,
it just didn't like coffee,
like I'm probably addicted to coffee.
I fucking love coffee.
I love coffee.
Tea or coffee?
Coffee is.
Is.
This is caveman coffee.
This is some delicious roast.
What kind is this?
Do you remember what roasted it is?
There?
Was that saber tooth,
was it.
Is it the same thing?
It was the end of one,
I think it was at.
Yeah.
God Damn,
that's it.
That delicious stuff with the silver
writing.
Woo.
That's good stuff.
Yeah,
it's really good coffee as far as uh,
right now I'm just trying to keep my
body is pure as possible.
I'm not even doing pre workout at all
because I'm so cognizant of what my
heart's doing is.
I'm pushing it so hard every day and I'm
always got my heart rate monitor on.
Even during that,
the ultra that I just did the 24 hour we
were running fast and never got above
141 or 42 beats per minute.
So I mean that when I take pre workout,
obviously it's going to ramp up my heart
rate and I just,
so my work definitely doesn't have to
worry about anything in me right now.
I'm just trying to stay calm,
stay a um,
like an efficient machine out there and
I'm feeling feeling good actually.
That's awesome.
Can you imagine if you took a pre
workout and you got pot from meth to
work and be like,
hey cam,
what the fuck you doing?
Eating healthy,
working out,
taking super jacked formula number six.
Oh,
let's test that meth head.
We have a real issue with that in the
UFC.
There a real issue with guys taking
these supplements.
Chad Mendez is a,
one of the latest ones take these
supplements that you buy from stores and
these supplements turned out to have
either steroids or hormone precursors or
different peptides that make your body
develop more testosterone or more growth
hormone or different things that are
banned by the U.
S,
Ada and a super common man.
Super Common.
And you know,
a lot of people like,
you know,
people online would love project.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
It was a tainted supplement,
but they're actually testing these
supplements.
When these guys get caught.
Like A,
for instance,
tim means he's a perfect example.
Like he was only suspended for a very
short amount of time.
They give him six months retroactive to
the day where he got caught.
He was supposed to have this fucking
amazing fight with cowboy serone.
That would have been an incredible
fight.
Yeah.
To me it was super,
super skillful.
So they take a,
Tim means,
uh,
he,
he tells them what the supplement was.
They go to a store independently,
take it off the shelf,
test it,
and they go,
she up.
Sure enough it has a steroid in it.
So there's a lot of this stuff that
people are buying that they think is
safe and easy.
If it works like that,
you know,
if it's like I put on 10 pounds and
three hours,
there's some shit in there.
Dude,
it's the stuff that works,
works a little bit where it's like a
little bit,
you get like a little bit of an
advantage,
like everything is everything that's
healthy and then legal that you could
use like creatine,
creatine works became like a little bit,
a little bit of a bump
and you can add a little bit of this,
a little bit of that and this stuff
helps that netapp helped ain't take this
before you go to bed,
it'll help your,
your growth hormone increase and that
stuff is like little incremental little
edges.
It works,
it all works but a little bit.
Yeah,
I did that with complete nutrition.
I think it was like 2011.
They had some of that stuff and as you
know,
did a,
taking a few different things and uh,
it worked,
it totally worked.
I definitely put on muscle and I was
like Dang,
this stuff is awesome.
So it got done,
went back in there like,
oh remember that stuff that is something
Nova or something like that.
They're like,
yeah,
they pulled that,
that's too strong.
And I'm like,
oh,
so that's it.
I mean,
it definitely worked.
The problem was a problem with that is,
you know,
like a young guys especially,
they'll take whatever,
but that stuff is hard on your liver,
you know what I mean?
Those supplements,
I'm going through your liver like that.
So it's uh,
it's also hard on your balls probably.
I took this stuff called Mag 10 bag 10
is the most powerful thing that I ever
took.
They pulled that off the shelf.
Oh yeah.
You used to take 10 clear pills a day.
You just looked like a total pill head.
I mean,
it's like a stack of these pills and
they're clear and they probably like
super toxic on your liver from God.
Damn.
Did I get dragged to.
Did it work?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
But it's,
you know,
you're manipulating your hormones.
Yeah.
And it's tricky doing that is tricky
because you have to really be concerned
with taxing your endocrine system.
Your endocrine system shuts down because
it's like,
well,
this,
why does this guy have,
you know,
all this God damn extra testosterone.
A system.
I guess we don't have to make
testosterone anymore,
so balls crash.
So your balls take a break and when you
balls go on vacation then it takes like
a couple of weeks for them to get back
up to speed after you're up,
you're done.
Because if you're on that stuff,
like say if you're on for like six
weeks,
I think they say it takes like at least
three for your body to get back to
normal.
We bought it to let go.
Whew.
Okay.
Really looks like a,
you know,
it's like your balls are like a haunted
house.
Like everybody goes in and shines a
flashlight around.
We.
Okay,
we'll go back to business now.
What the fuck was going on in here?
Is this guy taking,
you know,
your body's not used to you taking
something.
It's processed through your digestive
system and it's testosterone and all of
a sudden you're like,
what is this?
Where's it coming from?
Why is it coming from the liver?
Right?
What is this shit getting absorbed by
your stomach and your intestines?
This crazy testosterone stuff.
You know,
it's better just eat elk.
That helps.
That does help.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of different foods that
are apparently,
um,
that,
uh,
that are high in or that make your body
produce more testosterone.
Here's an interesting thing that a lot
of people are finding when they're going
on ketogenic diets,
and this is several people including me,
that I have done this where once you
start going on these ketogenic diets and
you get your testosterone tested,
and this is people that are on
testosterone replacement and people that
are not on testosterone replacement.
I've had three different friends who
have similar results where your test
just gets Jack.
So what turns out that fats are one of
the most important things like healthy
fats and essential fatty acids and,
um,
and even saturated fats and cholesterol
is one of the most important things for
your body to convert to testosterone,
for your body,
to produce testosterone.
It needs those precursors and needs
those,
those important important aspects of
nutrition.
Which is really interesting because for
so long people thought that low fat
diets were healthy and low fat was the
way to go.
Low Fat will make you have more energy.
You'll be healthier.
But it turns out that's not necessarily
true and it's weird because like what
was like doctrine 20 years ago or 10
years ago,
right now,
like a wound that's not the case.
You know,
I was reading my kid a book Dr Seuss
Book and it was a nutrition pyramid at
the bottom of the pyramid.
Like the most important shit was bread
and it was like bread and grains like
that is not.
No,
no,
no.
Where's the vegetables?
Right.
Why is that fucking.
Why is the bottom useless?
Calories like pasta.
That's so stupid.
Yeah.
And that's exactly.
People just pound that stuff in the
evenings and wonder why they can't lose
weight.
Yeah.
You know,
that's the biggest thing is those late
night carbs aren't getting burned up.
Well,
it gets converted to sugar and it also,
there's the insulin,
that's the real issue is a giant issue
with your body getting this insulin
spike and it's just not good for you.
It's just not good to have that much God
damn sugar.
It doesn't exist in nature in that form.
So we have developed these very weird
bodies,
you know,
and ever since I've been on this
high fat,
low sugar kick,
I've always,
always aware that people are overweight.
So it's natural.
You see it everywhere,
no big deal.
But it's stunning when you really start
taking an actual,
like an inventory started looking around
at all these people I know,
belly fat and fat,
neck,
fat,
arm,
fat and we're capable of so much.
And then you see people who,
you know,
and I understand people are going
through things or challenges that have
different challenges in their life.
I get it,
but our bodies are so amazing.
They don't have to let them get to that
stage for sure.
It's uh,
it's unfortunate because it's so hard to
change once you're at that stage,
it's so hard and you feel terrible.
You feel.
And again,
this is me talking about marathon
runners and talking shit.
I've never gotten enormously obese,
but I would imagine I've gotten fat
enough for.
I'm disgusted with myself.
Yeah.
And that's like,
you know,
10 pounds overweight.
Right?
But I think it just,
it's,
they feel like it's too much work.
It's almost like the idea of running an
ultra marathon,
so.
Right,
losing 100 pounds.
So much work.
It's no different.
So when you run an ultra marathon,
you don't think about you're running 100
miles,
you break it down.
I mean,
and so that's the same thing with losing
weight.
You can't think about,
hey,
I need to lose 100 pounds.
They think about winning that day right
now.
What are you going to do today?
And then you can worry about tomorrow,
tomorrow.
But somebody asked me like,
how do you stay in that a cryogenic
chamber for three minutes at 250 degrees
below zero.
I said,
I just count the 63 times.
Yeah.
And they're like,
that's it.
I go,
yeah,
that's all I do.
I can't go one,
two,
three,
and I get to 60 and I go,
we're done with one one.
And then I do it again.
And then by the time I get to the third
minute of just I'm shivering,
but I'm just counting to 60.
It's not that hard if you play a little
game,
right?
Well it's no different.
So if you wanted to try to do 25 reps in
the gym,
you don't do 25,
you five sets of five.
Exactly.
So you just break that down.
Everybody has every,
you know,
people are different.
People break things down differently.
Um,
you know,
I've been thinking about this big foot
$200 raise and I'm thinking well maybe I
should break it into 50 mile races,
you know,
just break it down for fifties,
try to get it done.
So it's a logical gates,
whatever.
I do that when I do the Hindu squats,
I do 210 do squats and the way I do it
as I do them by tens,
I just just do it and I have a clicker
so I can't cheat because you will
fucking forget while you're in the
middle of that,
you're like,
what am I,
I'm 30 and my authority or have to look
at the clicker.
So I count.
And then at the end I checked the
clicker to make sure I'm right.
There you go.
But I break it down in tens.
I just do 10 and then I do 10 more.
Twenty and then,
uh,
do it like that.
I think of it as each one being,
uh,
a 10 squat increment.
So then I'm going to get through.
It doesn't seem so daunting that I do 10
squats and I have 90 or 192 go.
I think of it as just each little 10,
10 squat little event that I'm going to
do.
Here's another 10 squad.
Yvette,
here's not intense.
Quite event,
but that's nothing.
That's not paying well compared to what
you're doing.
Yeah.
Are also taking a fucking rock and throw
it into a backpack.
Running up the hill.
That's ridiculous to not not running,
but yeah.
No,
it's because you're doing that now
though,
you know,
a lot of guys are not with your rock the
way you do it,
but many guys are taking sandbags and
packing them down just like they would
like if they were trying to.
If you had a heavy backpack and you
have,
you know,
seven miles to go to get back to the
truck,
there's nothing you can do,
but walk those God damn seven miles,
that heavy backpack,
it's not going to get out on his own.
No,
no,
and that's,
that's the thing is like,
that's just hard manual labor,
that's all there is to it.
I mean when you start hunting elk in the
back country or even deer in the back
country or whatever your bear,
you got to get that thing back to the
truck.
And so some,
there's some guys who can just boost it,
who don't train,
who can just say,
well,
I'll take some time and I'll get it out.
There's a few guys who can,
who can do that and just one step at a
time type thing.
Most guys have to train to be in that
position.
You know?
Most guys.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
It's,
it's,
it's very physically taxing.
You went to,
you and I were in Colorado and we packed
out that bowl.
Did,
what?
Did we walk like maybe six tenths of a
mile?
Yeah.
Mad most three quarters of a mile,
quarter mile at most records a mile and
you know,
we only had like 100 pounds on and
imagine like,
I think remy was the one who was talking
about it.
Remy Warren of the fabulous a show.
Apex Predator.
He was on the podcast talking about how
he had a pack or Moose out,
I think it was a moose seven miles.
Yeah.
And at the end he was just broken for
like months because his body was just
dead.
All I know it's it,
you know,
when I killed that Moose up in Alaska
with Roy,
you know,
our last time together a moose and that
was up over a big ridge into another
canyon.
It was four miles.
It wasn't seven like roomies,
but,
um,
it,
it was 600 pounds of meat.
So how are you going to get 600 pounds
of meat?
I mean,
it's going to be 100 pounds at a time
and up over the hill and Jesus Christ,
it's a grind.
But,
uh,
you know,
through snow down we walked,
really thought it'd be.
It was a better route just to go down
the creek,
like walk in the creek.
Yeah,
I,
I came up the,
the ridge.
He hadn't been in there that way,
up kind of up the ridge,
staying out of the creek.
He'd always come up the creek because if
you know,
really the hardest possible way to do
things,
that's how he wanted to do it.
So our first load out,
we were walking down the creek,
just feet,
you know,
if you ever mentioned walking into a
creek with 100 and some pounds on your
back,
you're the,
the elders are catching your backpack.
I mean,
it's exhausting.
So on the way back in,
I'm like,
dude,
we gotta stay up on that Ridge.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Love the ridge.
And it was just like,
probably five times easier.
Why would
walking in the creek be good?
The only thing I could think of is if
you were so hot from carrying all that
weight,
that it would cool you off a little bit,
but then you'd be wet now.
What his thought was,
uh,
you know,
there's so many,
so much.
The brush is so thick,
so if you're not fighting brush,
if you're in the creek,
you know,
usually the creek is pretty open.
He had cut,
he had cut it.
Um,
some of the brush has grown over the
creek out of the way,
so he sort of had a trail cut in there
and he came in there that the year
before he,
I think he killed a bull back in there,
so we sorta had a trail cut in there,
but the rocky walking in the creek with
the slipping and sliding and everything
else just,
it was,
uh,
it wasn't,
it.
We went on the road and he's like,
wow,
this is way better.
Reno is brother fucked as backup.
So bad that he had a by llamas.
Yeah.
He was carrying on an elk and apparently
he just fucked as backup.
Just Rinella in his brothers.
They're all savages.
They're all relentless.
Sure.
There are these fucking hill climbing
psycho goat people that just don't get
tired and they just push each other.
And I'm sure growing up they all pushed
each other like knowing Rinella and then
hearing the story about his brother.
I'm sure they're basically the same way.
And that I think he just said fucking
tough enough pussy.
And he kept going.
Just his back was just jacked.
So then he got llamas.
So now he takes these llamas in a van.
And when he drives,
he has these llamas.
Pack the meat out for them.
Yeah,
we hit me and really had llamas.
We bought Llamas for $100 a piece for
the exact same thing.
What is it like keeping a Llama?
You don't hardly have to deal with
anything real.
I mean,
when you pay $100 for them,
who cares?
So locked up,
falafel,
a poor slave lama.
No,
no,
but they're really hardy animals and
they can't pack,
you know,
they can't pack like a horse can pack.
But.
So if they packed 70 pounds and you've
got four of them,
well there's 280 pounds.
You're not packing on your back,
you know,
that adds up.
So that's all we had them.
And uh,
they would pack,
even if they didn't pack much meat,
they'd pack our camp and we could take
extra food and things like that.
So we'd go in the wilderness with our
four llamas and uh,
it was great and they just like hang
out.
Like they don't get cold now and they
don't need water either.
They're sorta like camels.
What?
Yeah,
you don't even have to worry about water
with horses when you have horses in the
back country.
A wrangling the horses is like a whole
different responsibility,
a whole extra responsibility.
You have to make sure they have water,
you have to,
you know,
feed,
they can kind of figure it out in the
high country,
but they have to get water every day,
you know,
so you can't be gone from camp with,
for an extended periods with llamas.
Who Cares?
Remy was on a horse hunt and they were
riding a horse and uh,
one of the guys was on the horse and the
horse fell and snapped his leg.
The horse broke,
his leg was broken,
his leg.
And uh,
the guide just said,
all right,
well everybody back up.
Shoot the horse and so remy was like,
well,
this seems like it just kind of like
leave it here.
Yeah.
So he cut the backstraps off of it.
Off The horse.
Yeah.
That have.
I mean,
thank you.
Cooked it too.
Did he say he cooked it?
I know I,
I had endorsed before.
Yeah.
I had horse.
Had An amazing restaurant in Montreal.
Joe Beef twice,
two different occasions.
They served as horse one time.
It was a.
You were like,
yeah,
no,
I wouldn't personally,
I wouldn't eat what I've seen horses
dead in the back country.
Same thing.
You wouldn't eat a horse.
Probably not.
Like if somebody,
if you went to a restaurant,
sucks super fancy restaurants like Joe
beef and they served you a horse
tenderloin,
I'd say,
Hey,
could I get that filet?
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't try it.
Probably not really to just try it.
I,
I was,
you know,
I grew up around horses.
I love horses.
Uh,
have written a lot.
And I remember I was hunting in
Australia with Adam Green tree and they
call them Brumby's back there.
So it's just wild horses.
And we were sitting there under a tree
is hot is,
I mean 120 degrees Fahrenheit.
It's crazy hot.
We're just sitting there boiling.
Here's this white stallion coming up
Rhombi.
And Adam's like,
oh that's,
that's a beautiful trophy and a this
whore.
What a beautiful trophy to shoot.
Yeah,
they shoot them.
But yes,
they're wild horses.
So was just a trophy.
What a weird way to look at a horse.
Well that's,
that's why people hunt,
right?
Is it for food?
I mean,
does he eat?
The horse
wasn't going to do with the horse I
shot.
People are going to be like fucking
psycho now.
The thing in Australia is all those are
feral animals,
so they need to be killed,
you know?
So there's no law that says you need to
take the meat off.
Whatever you kill.
They just want the animal's dead.
It was so strange.
There's too many of them.
I mean they'll,
they'll fly over a parks and just wipe
out the buffalo,
the water buffalo because they just
ruined all the water sources.
There's,
they don't get killed.
There's way too many of them.
They were introduced there from Asia and
so they need the numbers control.
They need them gone basically.
So yeah,
I mean a wild horse,
same thing.
Their um,
their sensibilities are so contrary to
ours.
When you think about what hunting is
over here and went hunting is over
there,
like for people that are like aghast
listening to this,
by the way,
Adam is fucking awesome.
I love this guy.
He's not a slight against him.
No,
he's amazing.
But his environment is very different
than our environment and this is what's
different.
Australia didn't have hardly any
animals.
I mean like Kangaroos and wallabies and
some weird shit,
but all the animals that they have there
have been introduced and they've made
some big mistakes along the way.
Yeah.
And one of the big mistakes was they
brought over foxes and they brought over
cats and uh,
this was a huge mistake because they
have wild cat everywhere.
Everywhere in Australia.
House cats,
right?
Regular.
Like house cats,
except they're wild as fuck.
And they kill everything.
They decimate ground nesting birds.
The ground nesting birds just go
extinct.
Like there's just,
they have no chance.
And cats are fucking murderers.
We've,
we've talked about this on the podcast
because we did this.
Uh,
we,
we read this study that was done
recently on how many animals cats killed
per year.
I have two cats.
I love cats.
They're awesome.
I've always had,
I've had cats my whole life.
I love cats.
So not a slight against cats.
Yeah,
they killed billions.
Billions.
I mean Bei Bei every year in America,
just in the US,
the fucking murderers and killed in
rodents and squirrels and birds.
They fucking killed everything.
So in Australian hunting magazines,
these guys are holding up cats.
Yeah.
Like with smiles on their face,
like they just shot a coyote or some,
you know,
murderous of willdabeast thing.
Not a wildebeest.
What's up?
Hold the piece.
Wouldn't be murderers,
some animal that you have to kill,
you know,
but they're,
they're holding up a fucking cat.
And you're like,
what?
Like he said,
he gave me one of his magazines while
these Australian Max.
Yeah.
I'm like,
this is cat killers incorporated.
Look what the fuck kind of magazines is
this.
A bunch of guys smiling with pictures of
cats.
Yeah.
But in their world,
right,
like this is a necessary thing,
like they have to kill these cats just
to keep the population and they're still
barely putting a dent in it.
Oh yeah.
Now.
And so the,
the end of my story is here comes this
white stallion,
20 yards.
Perfect.
And couldn't shoot it.
Yeah.
Couldn't do it.
Fuck that.
Can't kill a horse.
I mean,
I know.
Weird.
I haven't,
you know,
zebras are fairly close to horses and
appearance,
you know,
couldn't.
I've never hunted the zebra either.
I've been to Africa multiple times and
you know,
so anyway,
it's just,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not trying to judge anybody for
doing it.
I'm just saying for me,
Rinella had a really good take on this
whole cecil the lion thing.
And uh,
one of the things that he was saying is
as a hunter
who?
Cecil,
that's that guy,
the dude,
he had a brother named Jericho,
but his take on it was that as a person
who goes out and takes a life and,
and,
and does this like in a sort of a public
manner,
like you have an obligation to consume
that animal.
And so I was saying to him like,
well,
if you go over to Africa,
and he's like,
well I've never been Africa and I don't
have a desire to go to Africa,
but if I did and I shot a line,
I'd eat that line.
I go,
you would.
He goes,
yeah,
I'd eat that line.
Yeah.
So he won't,
he won't shoot anything unless you eat
it.
Okay.
And he's um,
he's actually been on many grizzly
hunts.
Yeah.
But he won't haunt coastal grizzlies
because he doesn't want a grizzly that's
been eaten fish.
He wants an inland grizzly.
It would be brown bear when it's coastal
and inland.
What's Grizzly?
Right?
So he wants an animal that is,
you know,
most likely eating berries or whatever.
So he can,
he can actually eat it.
It's good.
It's a good way to look at it.
Yeah,
I mean he could still eat the coastal,
I mean,
Holy Hell No.
I've eaten black bear that eat fish and
they're okay.
You know,
at Prince of Wales Island,
uh,
those blackberry salmon,
just like a grizzly and totally
different than like an Alberta black
bear.
Uh,
Albert,
Alberta black bear really good because
their grain fed,
it's like a grin.
Grain Fed beef,
right?
Um,
but you know,
that's like a white tail deer that lives
near a farm.
Yeah.
Like if you get white tailed deer that
lived near a farm,
mean they're eating Monsanto,
GMO corn,
right?
Yeah,
just Kinda,
you know,
look,
it's nature,
it's organic,
it's guaranteed.
That's good meat.
It's delicious.
But my buddy doug,
who's got a farm in Wisconsin,
Doug during shout out to my buddy doug,
uh,
his,
he has this amazing place in Wisconsin
in the driftless area.
You know,
where Cazenovia is.
I down about 90 minutes or so outside of
a.
What is the Madison I guess?
Yeah,
about 90 minutes outside of Madison,
somewhere around there,
but just as stunning place.
Beautiful.
And anyway,
these deer,
they're,
they're essentially almost like farm
animals.
Yeah.
And they live in conjunction with people
like their numbers have never been
higher and one of the reasons is because
we have these enormous farm areas,
like if you,
if it was like people who are not aware,
if you look at the United States,
if you look at the areas that are known
for being agriculturally strong,
like Kansas,
Iowa,
those are where all the bucks are.
Yeah.
That's where all the deer are.
If you go to those places.
Great Habitat.
Yeah.
I mean they live healthy and happy
because of these farms.
Yeah.
So they're almost farm animals in some
weird way.
A little bit.
I mean there's no,
they're not fenced in now.
Not fenced in,
but it's a lot of work.
They're tuned in,
man.
They're fucking ears are going left and
right.
They're looking for everybody there.
Keep
an eye on predators are notoriously
skittish.
Yeah,
they're tuned in.
They are very aware that their desired.
Yeah.
Someone's trying to jack them to just
like in the really big ones.
It's an interesting thing.
Um,
they don't come out in the daytime.
A lot of times they're only weaknesses.
The rut when it's breeding season.
And so then that's when that's a chink
in their armor.
So they're,
they want to breed,
they want to find that hot,
that dough that's in the heat.
It sounds like you in estrus
and you too,
Jamie.
I'm judging everybody.
It sounds like everybody.
But when you point at somebody,
you know there's four fingers pointing
back at you.
Not The way I point.
I point gangster style.
Oh,
this says all fire at Jamie and you at
some point I'm pointing to the devil.
My thumb pointing to you with my finger
and my other fingers are going to Jamie.
Well judge a way that makes you feel
better.
It does.
It's weird how it works that way.
It makes me feel way better.
They got better than people.
I just like to not look at my own fault
at all and I just,
it makes me feel super comfortable.
Right.
All I focus on is my fault.
So I'd like to.
I'd like to try your noble.
So Noble,
it seems like a lot of work,
but at these areas in our country that
are primarily agricultural areas that
have these massive deer populations,
that is the number one most hunted
animal in North America as white tail
deer,
most desired animal in America.
It's interesting how a mule deer,
which are also spectacular animals,
but conversely are almost totally wild.
These are mountain animals and nail the
occasion to go into fields and stuff
too.
And near farms for sure.
But uh,
finding a lot of these animals,
like they're just totally,
completely wild.
And for some people those animals,
because of the fact they're wild,
become like a more desirable animal.
Um,
it's like,
uh,
the mountains are,
I don't want to say Romanticize,
but people look at the mountains
differently.
It seems like,
you know,
just just being in the mountains is
powerful in itself.
So when you're hunting an animal that is
a mountain monarch,
so to speak,
a big bull elk,
sheep,
a very noble animal that lives
exclusively in the mountains and a
mountain mule deer in bowhunters know.
Especially,
you know,
I don't want to say I was going to say
Western boners no,
but any bowhunter knows that tries to go
after a mule deer and the mountains.
That's about as tough of a bow hunters
you're going to get.
I mean because elk,
for me,
I've killed most of my bowls.
Spa and stock.
I'm not calling them in and to stock and
elk is pretty easy.
I'm just compared to a mule deer.
Not Easy in general.
Just,
you know,
not like easy as going to a store and
buying a pop,
but easy,
easy to get close to them.
Yeah.
See,
compared to mule deer because
they're.
They make noise themselves,
so they're big animals.
Eight hundred pounds kicking rocks,
break and branches,
so they're making noises so you can get
away with some noise.
If a mule deer is laying up and it's bad
on top of a rim rock,
all it is is laying there at the back
protected because it's backed up against
a rock wall and it's looking down this,
the winds coming up so it can smell
everything that's below him.
Nothing you can get at them from behind
them and they're with their big ears,
you know,
that's what,
that's why they got the name mule deer.
They're uh,
they're big ears.
They're just listening.
All they're doing is observing,
smelling the wind and listening very,
very hard to get in bell range of.
Yeah,
that's a weird animal,
man.
It's uh,
it's interesting how they move to they
bounce,
you know,
like a lot of animals are running deer,
white tail deer mostly Kinda run.
But mule deer are literally bouncing up
in the air,
like some sort of a cartoon rabbit.
Yeah.
Point point.
I don't know.
I guess I've never even,
you know,
obviously I know that because I've seen
it.
I've spooked plenty of mule deer,
but uh,
I don't know if it's to get up and to
have a better view of what might have
spoke to them or what danger might be
there to be high.
I don't know.
I'd be interesting to find out why
there's any theories on why they do
that.
They kind of make sense.
If they live in fields,
which a lot of them do,
there's,
there goes one Boeing,
look at them go boing.
Boing,
boing,
boing.
What a weird animal.
That's fucking weird is a Weirdo.
They do that.
They this very strange look at the size
of his ears.
Yup.
Have you never seen a mule deer before
folks?
They have ears that are just enormous.
Yeah.
And he's bouncing,
pining towards a good book and they're
huge.
Yeah.
They.
Um,
and that's actually so an achilles heel
of a mule deer is those ears if it's
windy because all the hair in their ear.
So if the wind is really blowing and the
grass where they're bedded is blowing
around or that even the wind is blowing
the hair on their ears around,
they can't hear.
So if it's windy,
you can get close to them.
Uh,
if it's dead calm,
Foxville,
it's not going to be easy.
But if it's windy that's uh,
that's one way.
You know,
if I'm bowhunting,
if I had the wind right and it's
gusting,
I feel pretty good,
pretty good.
I can get in.
It is interesting too that these animals
that are more difficult to get to,
and this is a one thing that is contrary
to the way a lot of people think about
hunting,
lease at the highest level,
the animals that are the most difficult
to get to in the hunts that are most
difficult or the most prized,
and it's one of the reasons why people
like you gravitate towards bowhunting
because bowhunting is far more difficult
than rifle hunting and then the animals
that are the most difficult to bowhunt
become the most prized for a lot of
people like wild desert,
bighorn sheep.
They'll stone sheep,
dall sheep.
When you have to go to these really
crazy places that are really high up in
the mountains,
very difficult to get there in the first
place and then good luck sneaking up on
them.
Your wide out in the open on this
gigantic mountain with all this shale
and rocks and I mean those are the
animals that people prize.
In some strange way that these hunters
like the difficulty of the hunt,
the tougher it is to camp out there.
The difficulty in the conditions that
tough for those conditions are the more
people sort of like pro like praise
those kinds of experiences.
It's the challenge.
It's what it's why we bow hunt.
Um,
and that's just a,
that's just a prime example of the
greatest challenge there is,
you know,
in the mountains in those tough
conditions with a bow.
Um,
yeah,
it's hard as it get.
So we bow hunt because we like challenge
and we put those animals on pedestals
because they're the ultimate challenge.
Yeah.
And it's for people that don't hunt,
they don't,
they probably are not,
not only they're not aware of this,
but it might not even make that much
sense that this is one of the reasons
why those animals are like people
saying,
Oh,
you know,
it doesn't like how many times do I read
this?
It doesn't take any skill.
You know,
what you're doing is horrible entirely.
It's one of the most difficult things
you could do in the world if you want to
try to feed yourself with a bow and an
Arrow,
a stick,
and a string.
You want to try to feed yourself with
that?
Yeah.
Good luck.
The people that say there's no skill
involved in bowhunting,
haven't done it.
They definitely happen,
but it's also,
it's,
it's in a can in inconsiderate
convenient way of dismissing something
that they don't agree with because of
their ideology and with a lot of the
people.
There are people that eat meat,
which is really weird.
It's like you're eating meat and you're
dismissing someone who's doing one of
the most difficult things in the world
with meat.
Yeah.
Well,
I guarantee you.
No,
I know there's people out there who
don't hunt who,
um,
respect animals.
No,
I get that.
But those people could never have the
same amount of respect.
I don't think as a hunter who knows what
it takes to survive up there,
what it takes to outwit the animal up
there,
what it takes to be successful and to
get that,
that the meat off the mountain after
you've harvested one.
The amount of respect.
That whole process builds in a hunter.
There's no way.
Somebody who hasn't done it could
appreciate or match.
I don't know whether or not they could
appreciate it as much.
I just don't think they understand the
experience.
I don't think they understand the beauty
that some people find in that experience
because I think in their eyes,
if you take life,
this is a negative thing,
a terrible thing,
but the way I always kind of look at it
like that,
there's a storm going on out there.
Okay.
Close Your door.
Watch game of thrones,
sit in your air conditioned apartment.
Drink your soda and like,
Oh,
life is beautiful.
I don't know why anybody would go out
there and kill an animal.
There's a storm of animals killing
animals out there.
It's happening right now while we're
sitting in this beautiful air
conditioned studio here in lovely
Woodland Hills,
California.
There is a fucking storm or coyotes or
kill and deer and bears are killing each
other and that fucking picture that we
posted that you showed me,
I said I was going to post later today
of that polar bear carrying around that
cubs head.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
Real life that that's going on right now
and all you're doing is a hunter.
Is you're choosing to not go the factory
farm route and to make this experience
of gathering your food a massive
challenge and an incredibly rewarding
experience and you connect yourself to
the wild in some really bizarre way that
I never understood until I started doing
it.
Once I.
Once I started,
like I always thought,
well this is probably the better way to
get meat.
Yeah,
but once I started doing it this
logically,
you thought it made sense,
right?
Exactly.
Yeah,
but I had no real connection now,
but when you get that spiritual
connection with the animals that the
country,
the challenge,
your own human spirit and what it takes,
that's where the powerful,
how,
how powerful hunting is really.
It's driven home.
Well,
it's just,
it's,
it's kind of psychedelic in a way and
people had gotten mad at me because I've
said this and this is what I mean by
Psychedelic,
like the.
I mean even hunting an animal and
looking in his eyes.
It's psychedelic and some sort of a
weird way because it's,
it's paradigm shifting and it's,
it sort of,
it changes your view.
It like takes you out of perspective
shifting thing because when you're
actually in this animal's environment,
you're in this really quiet forest and
you're,
you're sneaking up on this animal and
you,
you're pursuing it and you're hunting it
and you lock eyes with this thing and in
this,
this animal's world,
this animal doesn't know anything about
culture.
It doesn't know anything about your
traditions or your rules or your ideas
or your ethics or what you think should
and shouldn't be done.
This thing is just trying to survive.
That's it and some very strange way
where it is.
Not only is it trying to survive,
it's trying to keep other things from
doing what it wants to do.
It wants to stab these other deer with
his antlers so that they can't fuck the
girls that it wants to fuck.
He wants to pass on its genes in some
incredibly primitive competition.
Yeah.
This gene competition that's going on
and some sort of a way where they're
not,
they're not.
They're not intellectualizing it.
Now they're not thinking about it like,
well,
what I want to do is pass on my name
because my boys are going to be the
hanes boys and their hands boys never
quit.
No,
they are not thinking like that.
They're not thinking there.
No nobleness it.
All it is is survival and and breeding.
It's some sort of a nature mathematics
thing that's going on and you know this,
this world is this savage,
primal,
crazy world and what you're doing as a
hunter is entering into that world.
Now,
what people who don't have don't seem to
understand is that the people that do
hunt are responsible directly for the
population increase of all these animals
and it's very contradictory in a lot of
ways.
These people,
they don't like the people that,
that don't like hunting,
but love animals don't understand that
the numbers are where they are now
directly because of people contributing
to wildlife preservation to habitat
preservation and to making sure that
wildlife biologist manage these areas
properly and that's like,
that's a hard pill to swallow for people
who love animals,
but the people who are spending the most
amount of money to keep these animals
healthy,
want to go kill them and eat them.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's like many things in life.
It doesn't necessarily add up the way
you'd like it.
It seems contradictory,
but hunters are why there's more,
you know,
we looked this up last time.
More deer,
elk bear Turkey numbers than there ever
has been in North America.
So I mean,
um,
I think elk is.
Elk doesn't occupy as much area as it
used to be,
but that was because the assholes who
were around in the 18 hundreds who came
along first or the 16,
17 and 18 hundreds.
They just shot the shit out of him know.
And they were doing it for me to stay
alive.
A lot of it was also,
uh,
Dan Flores,
who was on Ronell's podcast,
if you haven't listened to that and the
mediator podcast,
listen to this one because it's
sensational.
He's a wildlife historian and talks
about the history of wildlife in North
America and the same guys that killed
off massive amounts of buffalo in this
country and all of sudden almost made
them extinct.
They did the same thing with pronghorns.
They did the same thing with elk.
They just,
these were guys who came back from the
wars and they just had no skills other
than killing things.
And this was a way to make money for the
market.
So they would go out and just slaughter
wholesale slaughter of these animals
when they ran out of Buffalo,
they turned to the antelope and for hide
and for all these other things.
And you know,
human beings can be this incredibly
thoughtless consumer.
And I think that that's,
that's that connection for.
It's unfairly connected to hunting.
Yeah.
And some sort of a way.
Well now.
And that's,
you know,
Hunter's,
nowadays I think we're doing a good job
at driving home.
The point hunting is conservation,
you know,
rocky mountain now [inaudible] has
helped,
uh,
they coined that term and it's true,
you know,
hunters are out there doing,
doing the work,
paying the money.
Um,
yeah,
we're killing animals,
but it's to the benefit of the animals.
Also,
Ben.
Oh,
Brian has an interesting take on that.
Uh,
our friend Benno Brian who used to work
at Peterson's and now I'm worse at Yeti
coolers.
He says conservation is something that
comes along.
It's a byproduct of it.
But really it's about hunting.
Yeah.
And I think that's,
that's the honest answer.
Oh No,
I'm.
When I'm out there hunting,
I'm not thinking I needed to be the best
conservationists.
I can't.
I mean,
no,
I'm out there to be successful.
But that mantra,
it gets kind of,
it's an argument mantra.
It's like people that are hunting are
dealing with so much pressure from
people that are angry about hunting.
Right.
That and then this is a different world
too,
because you were saying when you grew up
that hunters were thought of as like,
wow,
this guy provides for his family.
He goes out and does this incredibly
difficult thing.
It's very noble hunters were looked at
with respect.
I mean,
you looked up to a hunter,
you're like,
you know,
if somebody was successful,
did you get your elk this year?
Yeah.
Oh Man.
You know that guy.
He's a stud.
It's tough to do.
Tough to do.
Went out and did it.
So hunters were put on a pedestal when I
grew up in the town I grew up and where
I lived and it was.
There was something,
you know,
you had pride that you hunted.
Well,
this is what I think is good about all
this controversy that when you were
doing this,
when you were young,
there was no social media and so you
weren't engaging with people that
thought in a contrary way that thought
different,
that we're upset by your actions and
they weren't engaging with you either.
Right?
They looked at hunters like elmer Fudd,
you know,
they looked at him like some guy hunters
in a movie or always this drunk guy was
out there shooting at anything that
moved.
Bad Guy,
the bad guy,
oh,
he's a bad guy,
and that was their perception and your
perception was based on your environment
where you're in an area that's pretty,
pretty rural,
a lot of wildlife,
a lot of hunters,
and it's a super normal part of the
environment,
the culture.
So these people that are urban,
that are just conditioned to thinking of
animals as being pet that you love and
food is being something that gets you
get from a grocery store.
Even the people that buy meat,
they're not involved in any way,
shape or form in the killing of that
meat.
So they're completely disconnected from
it.
So this,
even though there's like this craziness
going on where these animal rights
people are saying,
I hope your mother gets raped and killed
and murdered and gutted in front of your
children and all this crazy shit that
I've seen these angry,
angry people that think of.
Well,
I don't know if there's a lot going on.
I don't know if they're actually angry
in as much that made it into like a
logical progression where it makes sense
or if it's just they feel like they have
the right to go after you because you're
killing things and they're really just
fucking imbalanced.
There's a lot of that and there's a lot
of imbalanced people that do really good
things because it allows them to be
really aggressive in their negative.
They're negative behavior.
Like there's some people that love to be
negative and they love to be aggressive
and they love to be shitty and insulting
and and hostile and the way to ensure
that that behavior is not just accepted
but actually rewarded is to be negative
and hostile and even violent for a good
cause.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and so they're masking their really
psychotic,
fucked up behavior.
It looks.
One of the things like people's like
being a,
being an animal rights person or being a
Vegan is about compassion.
Except when you're talking to people
that don't agree with you and then
you're allowed to get fucking super
hostile and super negative and violent
and self righteous.
Call us murderers and say we deserve to
die and they would like to kill us.
So they're tolerant until you know
there's a cause.
A cause that you know is you have to
actually think to justify and you have
to actually look at the big picture,
you know,
but when it's easy and say,
Oh,
you hunt,
you're a murderer,
right?
I wish you were dead.
That's easy.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it's in it.
I understand it,
I understand it.
I understand where they're coming from
and I understand their perspective of
someone who actually does love animals.
I understand that this contradiction is
very difficult to deal with and that's
one of the things that I think is
important about this new age of
interaction is that some people are kind
of getting the understanding.
They're getting the message like,
okay,
I thought that this thing was about
these people that hated animals that
went out and shot him and killed him.
But now I'm seeing that this thing also
has a lot of different layers to it and
there's a broad range of these people
and the noble ones are actually doing
not just a service to the wildlife.
They're stewards of the wildlife and
stewards of the land and there are also
up there getting their food.
They're getting the healthiest food that
a person can eat right from the wild and
that this idea that you can somehow or
another have no harm and do no harm to
animals.
Well that's not true.
You can't do no harm.
And we said,
well,
you could do less harm.
Depends on what you think less harm
means.
Because if you're talking about bugs,
are bugs life.
If you're talking about rodents,
if you're talking about things that get
chewed up when they,
when they processed grain,
right,
you're not.
Animals are dying and if you,
and if you procreate,
boy,
that's a fucking ball of wax right
there.
That's a bag of worms or whatever it is.
What is the expression?
Bag of worms.
It was a bag of wax.
I can wax.
If you procreate,
boy your your you,
you are creating a beautiful little baby
human being that is going to consume and
it's gonna Cause waste.
It's going to burn fossil fuels into the
atmosphere.
It's going to promote global warming.
It's going to have plastic that most
likely will wash up into the ocean.
It's going to be a consumer of all these
things and there's no way around that.
So if you love people like I do,
I've hugged and love people.
People are destroyers.
Yeah.
Dislike.
You know,
just like bears eat cubs.
People make a certain amount of waste.
Yeah,
and hopefully we can figure out a way to
balance that out as people get more and
more complex in their ability to utilize
recycled materials and maybe even
possibly turn some of the waste that we
pump out into the air.
There was discussion about that,
about extracting pollution from the air
and using it as fuel and there'd be some
way to do that.
I don't.
I know that scientists are actually
trying to come up with feasible methods
of taking places that are just like
really polluted and actually using that
pollutants are those pollutants and
turning it into some sort of a product
that we can use.
They're smarter than me.
I know that me too,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm help.
I'm hopeful.
But what I'm saying is that we're all in
some way responsible for some sort of an
impact on the world that we live in and
just like dog shit on the ground and you
know,
cats kill every fucking thing they get a
chance to.
That's their design.
That's what they're supposed to do.
There's nothing more friendly to a
hunter.
I can tell you that,
you know,
if you're talking about,
um,
helping the environment,
getting out there,
killing yourself,
processing it,
bringing it home,
that's,
you know,
that's about as good as it gets as far
as ECO friendly.
And,
uh,
I think,
I think we're getting that message out
there on the positive attributes of
hunting.
I mean,
we've talked about this a number of
times.
You've talked about it with other guests
number times,
and I see,
yeah,
I still see a lot of hate,
anger,
misunder not misunderstanding,
but they don't want to understand.
It doesn't feel like.
But on the other side I get messages
from a lot of people who are saying,
I've never thought about hunting now way
I'm interested in providing for myself.
I wanted to be self sufficient.
I'm trying,
I'm getting a bow.
So I mean,
you know,
we're doing good things also.
I mean I know we,
we talk about the negative lot and we
focus on that.
I mean,
you know,
if you look at it,
if you look at my social media stuff,
I do notice the negatives.
I'm probably too much so I mean I know
we talk about that,
but man,
there's a lot of positive out there too,
is way more positive than there is
negative now,
but it's all in what you focus on.
If you decided to focus on the negative,
there'd be way more negative.
Yeah,
I mean you can definitely find it.
Yeah.
Just put Hashtag Vegan on all your posts
and watch what happens.
That's what you do.
I only did it once.
Oh my God,
I get so upset.
And it was,
it was over a joke.
It was a joke,
but it was,
it had meat in it.
Can't handle jokes now.
But I think that,
um,
just these conversations,
they're,
they're important.
It's also important for people that are
there.
They're in chanted by maybe a more
radical,
a animal activist perspective and you
know,
it seems to make sense,
but sometimes the that needs to be
balanced out and you need to consider
both sides.
And I think the hunting side is not
represented enough in an intelligent
way.
We're,
it balances out some of the more radical
and also proselytizing like they're
trying to convert people into their
world in a lot of ways.
Like a lot of people that are animal
rights people were Vegan.
People are really actively trying to get
people to do what they do and get super
upset when people find it unhealthy or
no longer do it.
Yeah.
It meanwhile,
95 percent of the world consumes meat 95
percent.
But when people go back and that used to
be Vegan and they say,
I just fucking,
my whole body's falling apart,
my hair's falling out,
my skin is to dry,
have no energy,
and this is a really common.
People say,
well,
it's because you're doing it wrong.
Not necessarily.
There's a lot of aspects like you.
I'm not saying you should or shouldn't
do it,
but there's a lot of aspects that if you
talk to an actual scientist,
real nutritionist,
people who are experts in human biology
and the direct mechanisms of absorbing
nutrients,
there's some real issues with plant
versions of many different things
including vitamin B.
Twelve have a bunch of different fatty
acids that although they are active in
some plants and seeds and oils which are
probably good for you,
they're actually not nearly as bio
available as fatty fish and you know,
Dah Da.
And a lot of,
um,
a lot of different essential fatty
acids,
Omega threes and sixes and all these
different things.
They're more,
more biologically available to human
beings in animal form.
And this is just science.
This is getting a forget about the idea
that you shouldn't do it because what's
talk about like what is good for the
human body itself,
but it's,
it's fucking hard to get the same stuff
from plants and if it's important to you
and you want to do it,
you can do,
you can.
But my driver yesterday,
um,
he,
he switched into was a Vegan.
He's a Vegan now and um,
so he was telling me that actually since
he started with his veganism,
he eats way less healthy because while
he's not eating meat,
he's eating potato chips and he's eating
all these carbs and all of these empty
carbs and there's just like,
yeah,
so I'm not eating me,
but man,
I feel terrible and I'm eating awful
Doritos.
There's no meat and Doritos but not that
great for you as well.
Sam Harris,
who was on our podcast recently,
he recently can be converted to being a
Vegan as well because of the honest
concerns with factory farming and things
along those lines.
And uh,
his blood lip,
it's,
we're all fucked up and he's like,
I gotta figure this out because you
know,
you're eating carbs all the time.
Your body just,
your insulin spikes,
your blood sugar level spikes.
It's just not necessarily healthy unless
you,
you have to approach it the right way.
You got to eat a lot of like healthy
things like almond butters,
really important nuts,
macadamia nuts,
you gotta,
you gotta find a way to get oils and
fats from your foods.
And also the way that affects brain
function,
it gets,
it's really important that you have a
certain amount of Omega is to really to
have your fucking brain conduct
properly.
It's like having good spark plugs in
your fucking car.
Well,
I ate a lot of meat and I feel pretty
healthy.
But it's,
it's also,
there's a debate where,
you know,
you say,
well,
someone who is a Vegan does less harm.
And that there's definitely an argument
for that.
If you accept a hierarchy of life.
And this is where it gets tricky because
what they're saying is that you should
not think that a human beings life is
more important that an animal's life
because that's speciesism.
Right.
Have you heard that?
This is new.
I said,
well,
I saw a Kat von d put up a little thing
on her instagram and it had,
it had like a man at the top of the food
chain basically.
And that was labeled as ego and then it
had man mixed in with all the other
animals and that was ego.
That's interesting.
Well,
ECO is man mixed in with all the other
animals if you eat them,
if you consume them the way they consume
each other.
I like,
I'm not saying it's egotistical,
but I'm saying man is a top of the food
chain.
Well yeah.
Duh.
And I don't have,
I don't,
I'm not hiding that fact.
I don't feel bad about that.
Now I'm a big fan of people,
but also a Kat von d needs to consider.
And I love cat.
Her tattoos are most likely not Vegan
inc is made with animal products.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's a part of tattoo ink and they do
have some Vegan inks now,
but um,
the idea that all those tattoos that she
has are all Vegan dot.
Alright.
Yeah.
That sounds rough.
What's better?
It was Vegan Inc is good.
Wonder if it's a one or if it's less
good.
I don't know if it's like Vegan chicken.
Let me,
I'm going to start protocols.
Taste.
Yeah.
Um,
but my point is the accepting the
hierarchy of life.
Because if you buy commercial grain,
you're directly responsible for an
industry that kills a lot of beings now
are the pesticides.
Unless you buy everything organic from
fucking handpick farm when you
absolutely know that no one had any,
absolutely no pesticides were done,
no one had anything that they put into
the ground that's dangerous to any of
the life that's not likely.
Now,
keep the likely case is that if you're
buying pasta or if you're buying rice or
if you're buying any of these things,
you're buying these things from some
sort of a farm that displaces wildlife,
kills,
massive amounts of rodents and bugs and
all these different things in.
Is a bug worth as much as the life of
NLC.
We need to make this discussion.
This is an important.
Is a mouse as worth as much as a white
tail deer,
right?
I don't know if it is,
but I know that millions of rodents are
killed in this country every year with
green combines and with that
illustration where all the animals are
mixed in with the man.
I guess everybody's equal,
right?
So why would it be okay to have wheat
harvested?
Buzzards flying all around that field
because of all the carnage down below
and they're scavengers,
so all the the road and saw the,
the rabbits,
all the pheasants,
even white tail fawn,
maybe all the animals that are killed
and they're.
They're coming down to eat those.
So in the harvest of that wheat bread
for that week or the week for the bread,
all of these animals died.
Well,
if everything's equal,
why is that okay?
But hunting isn't,
it doesn't make any sense.
No,
but it's,
it's a convenient way of looking at
things and it's also like bug spray.
I used to live near an Ashram in boulder
and uh,
the fucking lady who ran the restaurant
was poisoning nance.
And I go,
Hey,
what'd you do when she was using ant
poison?
She's like,
well,
we do what we have to.
Sometimes when we have ants would go,
you're not supposed to.
You're a vegetarian.
She's a Vegan and you don't believe in
killing life unless these conti bugs at
that tried to invade your camp and then
you kill them in mass with toxic
chemicals.
You spray from the sky in these
canisters of death.
I mean,
what a weird sort of a game you're
playing in your head about life and
death is an insect's life worth less
than a mammal's life.
Well,
why is that?
because an insect is not as much aware.
You ever tried to Swat a fly?
Yeah,
there's a reason why they get the fuck
out of the way.
They don't want to die.
They know.
Okay.
So,
but is an insect's life worth less than
a mouse?
Some people would say yes.
Okay.
Why is that?
Well,
a mouse is a had as emotions and see.
Okay,
okay.
Alright,
well then we're accepting a hierarchy.
Well,
these animals that can't communicate,
they're not as good as people.
Okay,
so we're going to eat them because it
makes you healthier.
That's,
I mean,
is that we accept in this.
No,
we're not.
Well then you got to stop eating grain
man,
because you're,
you're,
you're a part of wholesale slaughter.
You have to.
Well,
I think it goes back to,
uh,
there's a lot of hypocritical people
there,
but they're prostitize.
This is where it gets really weird.
I was watching this guy give this
argument about how human beings are not
designed to eat meat.
That's why we can't kill an animal with
our hands and our teeth and we have to
cook it in order to process it.
That's the only way our body consumes
it.
Well,
guess what?
Fuck face.
Try eating wheat.
Yeah,
try pulling rice out of the ground and
eating that.
We process everything,
man.
We process.
We process rice,
we process many grains and beans.
We process a lot of shit because we're
smart.
We figured out how to use tools a long
time ago.
Yeah,
we figured out how to burn things.
It makes it compatible and your body
adjusted to the fact that you were
cooking off the bacteria and these
things all the time.
Your gut flora changes.
There's a whole process going on,
man.
There's a whole evolutionary process
involving tools and fire and that's why
we have cities and that's why you have a
fucking youtube account where you can
make these ridiculous claims in the
first place.
It's all designed by people overcoming
the wild environment because I don't
know if you checked,
but we're fleshy.
Little water balloons of blood.
That's what we are.
We're.
We're really vulnerable.
Without all these tools and all these
houses and all these fucking people that
figured out fire and metal and all this
shit long before you were alive.
The reason why you're alive today is
because really ingenious,
inventive,
industrious people figured out how to
survive in a world where we could shit.
We're weak and vulnerable and the
animals come in and just her jack and
things left and right,
and we're out there with their little
baby in this world.
Did you hear about the fucking 15 year
old kid?
They get pulled out of a fucking tent by
a Hyena by his face.
He got yanked out of a fucking 10 by his
face.
Oh,
we're going to go on a happy camping
trip.
This kid is just hanging out in the
natural world.
I love animals because they love you
too.
You Fuck?
They love to eat.
You look at this boy.
15 had his face chewed by a Hyena as he
slept in a tent next to it.
Carrots in the Kruger National Park.
Yeah.
That's.
That's the real deal that his bones were
crushed.
Like a packet of crisps.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Hyenas are brutal.
Teen was conscious throughout the attack
and now undergoing surgery.
Oh Huh.
Only saved when his uncle heard him
being dragged like a blanket Hyena was
looking for food had been seen in the
week before.
The attack.
If you've ever seen a Hyena hose,
things are.
I mean they're killers.
Yeah.
Well that's why they're there.
That's why they're there.
Nature has this very efficient system.
All they do is kill and they don't care
what it is they're killing it.
Well,
Africa in particular is so fascinating
to me.
I was going to go on vacation there with
my family this year,
but I found out we'd have to get a bunch
of shots.
You went to Tanzania,
did you get a bunch of shots?
I'm not giving my six year olds some
crazy shots so they can endure Zika,
that Orient Malaria.
That's a big one.
How much did you have to.
What kind of shots did you have to get?
I don't know.
I got like I think four different shots,
but you know,
when I was in camp there,
there was uh,
one of the workers there had malaria.
It's not what you want to get.
And what was the,
what was it like a,
he's just weak and you know,
sick and given him antibiotics,
I don't know what they're doing.
Yeah.
I wonder if they even have antibiotics
and a lot of places.
Right?
I don't know.
I mean it's a lot different than here,
but it's a,
it's a brutal place.
Well,
life is
in this weird cycle.
We are so soft here.
I mean,
I just think we're getting weaker and
weaker.
Um,
but yeah,
over there,
if you're a week,
you're gone.
Well,
everywhere where it's hard.
When,
when things get rough,
when things are not rough,
that's when people can relax.
And that's one of the beautiful things
about cities.
We figured out a way to put up these
concrete structures that nothing can get
in.
No,
no wild things can get in and you can
take a break,
relax and eat chips,
get fat.
But I hate it here.
I like it.
I like it in the mountains where I am
vulnerable,
where,
you know,
hopefully my training and my experience
and whatever keeps me alive.
But also there's a weird sort of
electric feeling to that world,
this like a,
I want to say electric,
but it's stimulating feeling to that
world when you're walking around in that
world and you're acutely aware that you
are now part of this system and that you
could turn the wrong corner,
run into a fucking grizzly bear.
You could turn the wrong corner and run
into a mountain lion.
It doesn't happen a lot,
but it could happen.
You could fall,
you know,
like your friend Roy.
So it's,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
that's where,
that's where I feel most alive
obviously,
because you have to be,
you know,
if you're not in tune,
um,
who knows what happens.
It seems like also that there's some,
some reward systems that are built into
being a human being.
They get like little switches that gets
snapped on when you're out there that
you didn't,
I didn't even know existed.
And it's what I've seen with many people
who are very smart people who become
hunters,
who then they start talking about it.
They articulate really similar thoughts
that it becomes a,
the the,
the act of consuming becomes very
different when you acquire it the hard
way.
Yeah,
same as.
There's a feeling that you get is a much
more muted version of it,
but it's a really good feeling that you
get when you grow a salad and you're
eating that salad grew in your own yard.
Yeah,
but that's a much more muted.
It's a,
it's a beautiful feeling.
It feels nice.
It feels satisfying,
but it's much more muted.
Like when I cook an elk steak.
Yeah.
That's something that I,
I,
I was there for the entire time,
you know,
when it got shot,
helped cut it up and carry it out.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a memory attached to that.
There's a primal satisfaction attached
to that and there's also this feeling
like,
I know that thing wasn't penned up.
I know that thing didn't get stuffed
full of hormones.
I know that thing didn't get tortured
before it died.
I know it wasn't corralled into this
area and then they shoot a fucking
piston into its brain while it's
watching.
All of his friends die in the same way.
Yeah,
I know it.
I don't know if they know.
I don't know if they have friends
though.
Debt buddies to hang out.
They have a pit in the pin.
They hang out until,
until pussies out like many other
friends.
Then the backstabbing begins.
Literally.
They stab each other in the back with
their antlers.
It's brutal out there.
But yeah,
I mean I,
that connection a hunter has with it
with the animal and,
and just be able to bring that home and
cook it up and sit around the table.
That's just with your family.
I mean,
that's how it's always been.
That's how it's always been since the
beginning of time.
Being a provider is a powerful thing and
I wonder if this new trend away from
the.
I wonder what's going on with human
beings and uh,
if it is just a natural progression of
creating structures and safety and
society in the sense of civilization,
the way we think of it today,
I wonder if it's a natural sort of
progression to slowly but surely move
away from that world,
that wild world,
and to get more and more accustomed with
the idea of us creating our own food
from some other way,
like by detaching from how you grow your
vegetables,
by detaching from where your meat comes
from,
that were like setting ourselves up to
go further and further down this road of
not really being an animal anymore.
Being some new kind of weird thing.
I'm not going that way.
You're not going,
well,
you're not going that way,
this,
this life.
Now in this life,
you're,
you're in this sort of a transitionary
stage.
Or the culture is our society as a
demon.
Ends are.
You're digging and digging in as a,
as a hunter.
You're going old school staying old
school,
but it me as a person who like halfassed
scientist who tries to study human
beings trying to figure out what the
fuck I'm doing.
I wouldn't even use the word scientists
loosely,
something else,
whatever I am,
but when I look at it,
I'm always like,
what is going on here?
Because there's clearly something going
on with human beings as an organism.
Like there's something going on where
we're moving away from the natural world
with cities.
We're moving away from the natural world
with our ability to control our
environment.
It's hot as fuck outside right now and
you and I feel great.
How are you feeling,
jamie?
Field?
Great.
Ace is nice,
right?
It's beautiful.
So we figured out a way to live in these
harsh environments with no consequences
whatsoever except on in the environment
itself.
It's consequences about the.
But there's also this detachment from
the concerns of the world and it's one
of the things that I've always said
about La is that La is one of the most
unnatural places in the world because
not just because everyone's full of shit
because they're trying to get you to
think there's something they're not.
So you put them in a TV show or a movie,
but also because it doesn't rain here.
Yeah,
it's always perfect.
You could sleep outside and you're fine.
There's not that much wildlife worry
about.
There's so many mountain lions,
they killed all the deer.
You don't even get in car accidents
against deere.
Like our connection to wildlife is like
fucking nil.
Yeah.
I,
I don't think being comfortable all the
time.
I don't think,
you know,
La and cities
like La.
I don't,
it's not good.
I mean it's not good to,
to uh,
eliminate all the challenges of being a
human.
I mean,
that's why.
That's why I like getting out there and
just being immersed in challenge because
I don't know.
I mean,
how do you appreciate how good you have
a when you never have it hard?
That is a big point.
That's a big point.
It's a big point.
That was hammered home for me when I
came back from Prince of Wales.
From unsuccessful hunt.
Yeah.
We're out there for five or six days I
think,
and it was pouring rain every day.
It was cold as shit.
Every day your fingers are pruned up and
you're freezing your dick off and you
just can't wait to get back home and
when I got back home to La,
my God,
it was glorious.
I called up or now I go,
dude,
I don't think I've ever been happier in
my life.
Everyday was like so nice.
I.
It felt so good,
like it was so nice to see my friends.
It was so nice to to see the sun.
I called up Callan and he said the same
thing.
He's like,
dude,
I feel great.
I just feel so thankful to be back.
I feel so thankful to be in a city where
I don't have to worry about where my
food comes from.
We don't have to worry about starving to
death.
Yeah.
It makes you appreciate this weird thing
that we've gotten and I think when you
don't experience both things,
that's when you take it for granted.
Yeah.
So if you never would have went,
you never even had those feelings.
You know,
and I,
I think it's important.
I think it's an that's why I like when
people want to take on the challenge of
hunting,
want to learn more about it.
Um,
the byproduct yet we've talked about the
positive byproduct is you're
conservation is another byproduct is
you're going to realize what,
what it's like to be uncomfortable and
then,
you know,
conversely you're going to realize how
good we have it and um,
how you appreciate being able to walk up
to the tap and fill up a glass of water.
I mean,
I've been on a lot of haunts were just
getting water was like,
okay,
here's the focus of the day.
I need to find water.
Yeah,
that's it.
Well,
you were drinking buffalo piss water.
Yeah.
When you guys weren't.
This is a crazy story because it also
involved crocodiles when you guys were
in Australia and you decided you and
crazy fucking Adam green tree decided
let's bring no food.
Go out into the Bush where it's 120
degrees.
We'll definitely shoot a buffalo and
we'll just eat that.
Yeah,
yeah.
We're,
we're gonna.
We're gonna live quote,
live off the land.
And uh,
that's probably just happy he found
someone dumb enough to do that with them
Saturday night.
I can't believe you listened to me,
mate.
Everybody else has me to fuck off.
Yeah,
it hit him.
And a Owen Strano was there too.
But uh,
and Owen,
I think he might've brought man.
Did he,
would he have maybe a,
some kind of a,
a bar?
I don't know what he had.
I had half of a trail mix thing that I
bought at the airport,
you know,
and that,
that was like gold,
but yeah.
So we're going to live off the land and
uh,
yeah,
it was,
it was miserable.
But,
uh,
so did he talk you into this?
Was it your idea or his idea?
Like who?
It was,
his idea,
of course.
No,
it's great.
I thought sounded awesome.
He's out there shooting the horses and
cats should go.
Come on.
Let's live off the land.
No,
I thought it sounded great.
I mean it was fine.
It was,
you know,
I'm used to being miserable.
A little food would have been nice
because as you know,
like I said today I need to eat like
every hour because you run so much.
Actually I'm starving right now.
But uh,
that's uh,
well before we launched the new Cameron
Hanes podcast,
which we will this afternoon.
I,
we'll get you a protein bar.
There you go.
Alright.
I saw I saw a quest bar back there.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
We've got boxes of shit back there.
Plenty of I'm going to steal.
But yeah.
So just,
just living off the land took on a whole
nother challenge to a hard hunt already.
And so I was down for sure.
So you guys were eating only things that
you had shot and then drinking water
that you found in the water that you
found was all filled with buffalo piss?
Yeah,
because again,
too many buffalo,
I mean,
when you say too many,
if you,
if anybody's ever watched any of the
videos on the numbers of buffalo from
Asia,
these are enormous.
What do the Cape Buffalo,
whatever they know,
these are water buffalo water buffalo
and North Cape Buffaloes.
African won the fight the lines.
Yep.
Enormous giant beasts that are videos on
that.
Jamie.
Huge,
huge herds of these things.
Yeah.
No,
but they're pretty wary still.
I mean they're big animals,
but uh,
they're not quite,
not quite as worried as a Cape Buffalo,
I don't think because they don't have
lions hunting them,
you know,
but when they're around water,
they're used to,
the crocodiles been in there.
They definitely are,
are used to,
uh,
looking out for themselves.
So they're huge animals.
Um,
they can be dangerous because just
because they're so big.
But uh,
it's their survivors for sure.
If that's another weird animal to hunt
in Australia,
they hunt domestic cows.
Yeah,
call him scrubble scribbles.
Yeah.
And what a scrub Boulez is a domestic
cow that got loose,
you know,
many,
many generations ago and now have become
completely feral and you're dealing with
bowls and you know how like when you
ride bulls folks that they buck and kick
and you know how the matador stands in
the middle and the bull just fucking
charges him.
Tries to kill him.
Yeah.
That's what bulls do in the wild times
10.
So you have these wild for hyper
aggressive masses of muscle.
And this is a video,
it says cams raw.
What does it say?
What does the net cams.
Raw and uncut.
Ozzie water buff heart shot.
Yeah.
And this is you sneaking up on this
massive animal.
You've got to walk super slow.
Yeah.
The thing about it is a,
they'll pick up movement,
but as he's feeding there,
I know I can move so I just go very
slowly.
I had my range finder up near my face so
I don't have to reach for it and,
and do a bunch of extra movement there.
But if you,
uh,
how far away is he?
Right here?
Probably 50 yards now with the animals.
Is that big?
Why did you decide to keep walking
towards him?
Closer is better with a bow.
Right.
So you,
you felt like you could get closer so
you might as well just keep going until
you realize that you have to draw.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
when he.
I'm waiting for them to get broad side
because it's an animal that big.
Um,
you have to,
you just have to wait for a good
broadside shot.
And so here I am arranging them as I
walk and now he's getting ready to go
broadside.
That's an important point,
man,
because shot placement is something that
people that don't understand hunting
don't know how difficult it is to not
just have a shot on an animal,
but have an animal be in position to
take the shot.
I was watching a television show on guys
that were hunting water buffalo with a
bow and Arrow and I saw a guy take a
frontal shot.
So He's,
he's,
he's not feeding,
so I'm not moving because he's.
His head's up with this peripheral.
He could see me.
So he thinks something's going on here.
He's not.
He probably caught something.
I mean his ears covering his eye right
there.
You've got to be that focused.
So I know he's not looking at me right
now,
but he had,
he might've thought he saw something so
he just kind of chilling out.
June is cut.
And how hard is it to stay still here?
It's,
it's all right.
But I need,
I need him to go broadside.
I need that close leg to go forward
because if I just draw back and shoot,
you know,
without that guaranteed going to be
unsuccessful.
So I need that,
that lady to go forward that close like
right here now that opened up his
vitals.
Boom.
Perfect.
Right in there.
And how far away was that?
That was 39 yards.
So their,
their heart sits a.
I mean that you see that blood coming
out right now.
The heart sits like right next to it.
It's,
it's,
it's fine,
right?
It's forward.
It's forward from an elk would be a
little more back.
But basically you have to go right
through that front leg.
And uh,
I shot it really heavy Arrow and 90
pounds,
that's a 90 pound weight right there.
And you can see he's,
he's already week,
so it's only been,
you know,
maybe a minute and he's,
he's about done.
So you have to actually shoot through
the leg itself to get to the heart
unless he's quartering away from you.
Maybe.
Yeah,
quarter in a way.
The problem is they're so big,
so if it's too to quartering away their
stomachs big and it's full of grass.
So that could essentially be like for an
Arrow to go all the way through a bunch
of grass,
wet grass.
I mean probably not going to happen.
And you're shooting through ribs that
are as thick as two by fours,
right?
So what a crazy animal he's about bled
out right here.
And,
and the thing with a bow,
I mean these things fight each other.
So he has no idea what happened.
I mean,
he's just like no clue that he's used to
getting jabbed with horns or tree
branches or all sorts of stuff.
All he knows is he's
lost a lot of blood and boom,
it's over crazy.
Yup.
Now you guys,
when you went there and you didn't bring
any water with you,
you have to filter that piss water
somehow,
right?
Yeah.
What are you,
what do you filter it with?
We had a water filter and we had a
steripen.
What's that?
It's just like ultraviolet light.
You put in the water,
you hit it with the ultraviolet light
and then it supposedly disinfected water
supposedly is a key world.
The only reason why I throw out that is
because we filtered it.
We stare a pendant,
we poured it through a shirt and it
still smelled like buffalo pis.
Well,
it is buffalo pis.
We drank paralyzed buffalo pet.
We drank it and we didn't die.
I saw something online the other day.
They were trying to figure out how much
of the ocean is whale piss.
Like how many?
How many whales are there?
How long had they been peeing in the
ocean?
Right.
How much of that?
Where does it go?
How much of the ocean as well pissed and
we should protest them doing that.
Was dirty,
stinky wheels.
Yeah.
So selfish.
I saw a sad thing though,
man,
where this whale died in.
When the,
uh,
blue whale was beached,
they examine the contents of its stomach
and it was filled with fishing nets and
plastic bags because apparently whales
eat a lot of squid and they get confused
at that stuff,
like plastic bags and things along those
lines.
And they think that it's food and then
they got an intestinal blockage.
So it died by being backed up.
Yeah.
That's a rough way to go.
That is too bad.
They don't have whale doctors either in
the ocean where they go,
Hey doc,
I'm not feeling so good here.
So something's going on.
I haven't shaved in a week.
I'm going to check you out.
Yeah,
no,
my whale is coming out.
Bloody good.
The world,
the world of harsh nature.
We live in that world.
We just don't think we do because we've
created this super cool thing called
cities.
Yeah.
I don't think it's so cool,
but we definitely created it.
You're crazy.
You're wearing clothes that was created
in cities.
You're going to watch those creating
cities,
your,
uh,
your bow was created in the city.
I have a fit band.
I don't have that same thing.
It doesn't tell you the time.
I think it does.
Yeah.
Come on.
It's got to tell you the time it says I
got all time.
Record seven hours and 49 minutes sleep.
Oh,
that's an all time record.
Well,
congratulation recently.
Congratulations is in order.
It is.
That's what happens is you get to stay
in a hotel to work that day.
Yeah.
No,
it actually does have the time.
Sorry.
There you go.
So you've got to watch a car that you
have to drive around to get to these
hunting spots that's all created in a
city or you gotta go all this technology
created by people in civilization that
we're allowed to relax,
not worried about being eaten by wolves.
And they said,
hey,
uh,
these regular bows that we're using are
kind of bullshit.
We need some cams and these things,
right?
Like as
you pull it back,
it lets off at a certain weight and then
it's got more power going forward.
And a bunch of engineers went to
schools,
they wrote things down on paper and
uncover all that stuff created in
cities.
Yeah.
So like the city and the transition that
some organisms are going through from
wild to civilize actually makes it
possible for you to exist in the wild
world.
Again,
just like they'll hunting is
conservation thing.
How ironic
is something positive to a city?
Is that what you're saying?
Oh,
100 percent.
One hundred percent.
Listen man,
I'm not into working at a factory for 16
hours a day making iphones,
but if somebody wasn't,
I wouldn't have an iphone and I wouldn't
be able to tell you that you've got to
press that button twice or shut off your
apps.
I did learn something today like you.
We all need each other as awesome.
And for a guy like you who is so
invested in living in the wild and
having this challenge of being in the
wild,
you need your nice under armour clothes
to keep your comfy and warm and drive
and you're out there.
You've got your under or boots that were
made in some sort of a factory and
designed by some sort of an engineer and
you got your,
uh,
your watch tells you what altitude
you're at,
all that stuff is,
is a part of your experience in this
wild world.
You know,
you got your gear and you got your sat
phone so you could call home,
you know,
hey,
I just shot the biggest pool of my life
out here in the wild.
I'm talking to you from a fucking
satellite under miles in space.
But that's one reason why I'm not the
greatest when they send me stuff to try
out because um,
I like being miserable.
I'm not the greatest for feedback.
So how it perform,
I'm like,
you like being slightly miserable.
Otherwise you'd go out there naked.
Right,
right.
You know,
because that's one of the,
that's one of the big arguments that the
non hunters will use against the hunter.
Like,
you're a real man.
Why don't you go kill the fucking oak
with your wounds?
Right.
Why don't you go out with your hands?
Well,
that's not the way to do it.
Dummy things,
because you're not going to kill any of
them.
You won't kill them.
That's not how you killed them.
Right?
You know,
just like a rattle snake doesn't kill
you unless it uses poison.
Rattlesnake just tried to,
if they didn't have any poison and
wanting to fight me,
are we going to do.
You're going to stab me with you.
A little stupid needles.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to crush your fucking head
with a rock.
Stupid because I have an opposable
thumb.
So after you stabbed me with your
needle,
that doesn't have any venom in it
because you want to play fair.
Oh look,
I grab you by your head.
I smash it with a rock.
I wind dummy.
Wait,
that makes sense though.
Dang it.
Well,
it makes sense because I'm a human being
and I come from a long line of human
beings and human beings had been
thinking and more importantly we've been
communicating.
We've been communicating with language
and uh,
we,
we remember things that we learned and
we pass it on to others.
So I think what's going on now,
even though it seems negative and it
seems weird,
and the world of wildlife and hunting
and hunters versus people who don't
hunt,
I think ultimately it all balances out
really well because it all balances out
in an honest way.
There's going to be people that don't
agree with things no matter what,
just like there's gonna be people that
don't agree with a lot of different
things that a lot of people think are
fun.
There's going to be disagreements,
but in those disagreements we're going
to find arguments that make sense and
arguments that don't make sense.
We're going to find people that are
disingenuous and that are not being
totally honest with scientific facts
about nutrition,
scientific facts about whether or not
humans are omnivores or herbivores.
Uh,
there's a lot of dishonesty because
these debates are not debates about
facts and reason.
There are debates about ideology and
they only,
they only promote and subscribe to ideas
that benefit their ideology.
That's it.
And you get it on both sides.
That's one of the problems with the
hunting is conservation hunting's
hunting.
Yeah.
Ben O'brien's.
Got It right.
Funding to conservation is a byproduct
of hunting and hunting.
Even if it wasn't conservation,
it was just.
It was just something you do to eat.
It's still.
It's still good.
Yeah.
Still good.
No.
This conversation is important though.
Yeah.
People will talk to for your hunting.
That's a big one man.
He goes,
dudes.
Joseph Toy.
You're hooting.
Yeah.
It's true.
Just communication.
Yeah.
About something that,
you know,
I read your fucking instagram.
Yeah.
It's important.
It's A.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
I don't,
I try not to engage in the,
in the negative stuff on that,
on instagram,
but I do.
I do talk about the positive attributes
of hunting.
I show,
you know,
skinning out bare.
I show my fees,
freezer full of meat.
I show working hard to be the most
effective ethical hunter I can be.
So yeah,
I try to share all of it.
Yeah.
But you also have people that back you
up.
That's kind of interesting that people
know that,
so you don't have to really engage in a
bunch of campaigns.
Soldiers out there.
Guys,
you're fucking instagram page the
battlefield whenever you put some animal
up,
all my goodness,
and it's a lot of Europeans ally now
it's that they're the most detached
because they have the fewest percentage
of hundreds over there.
Yeah,
I mean I always get stuff from over
there.
They just have no concept or people.
Even Brazil,
you know,
you get just.
Brazil's a big one.
Yeah,
that's a big one.
Yeah.
A lot of hate from there.
Um,
yeah.
Someone was talking to me about that the
other day.
Someone was saying like,
how many people get upset about it
might've been shamed.
Was it Shane Dorian?
Um,
but there's what you,
when you hear the Robin Hood Story,
like when people think about Robin Hood
Robinson and bridge and gives to the
poor.
What people don't understand is that was
originally about food.
It was about him being able to hunt on
private land that the king owned because
people are starving.
That was the original story of Robin
Hood.
It's about Robin Hood going out and
shooting these animals and bringing meat
back to people.
Because in Europe,
in a lot of countries you are only able
to hunt on private land because there is
no public land.
We are incredibly lucky in this country
in that I was in yellowstone this
weekend,
told you I went up there and fucking
amazing man.
What an amazing thing and that's a non
hunting thing,
right?
Yellowstone.
You can't hunt there,
but this concept of public land,
this concept of more than a million
acres,
I don't know how many millions of acres.
Yellowstone is a big,
big chunk of property,
credible place that they can't build
things on.
You can't replace it,
can't put them all there and it's just
wild and natural and it's ours.
It's by an act of Congress.
Back before they had fucking cars wrap
your head around that.
They figured out before they had cars,
they're like,
Yo,
we gotta do something about this place.
This is too good.
Yeah,
we can't let anybody corrupt this and
this is what was wrong with where we
came from,
where we came from.
Everybody owned all the land.
It was all private and no one.
You didn't have a place where you could
just go backpacking and just camp out.
We have all these designated areas,
designated areas that are all public
land owned by the taxpayers of the
United States and whether you appreciate
hunting or whether you just appreciate
camping or hiking or any of those
things.
We have a beautiful thing in this
country.
Whereas the wild world that we're the.
The actual beautiful environment of
these forests and most of the areas are
in a lot of the areas.
All the areas designated as public land.
They're ours.
They're yours there.
Jamie's there.
Everybody that's listening.
All every,
all the people that live here and even
if even if the listeners aren't gonna
hunt,
which fine not everybody has to hunt,
but I would say get out there to
yellowstone or there's some national
forest here in California,
some great.
Just get out there and experience life.
You know?
I mean because living in the city isn't
experiencing life well.
It's experiencing life in the city.
It's life that's.
But it's not.
It's almost like you have a TV that only
shows three different colors.
You get a little bit of red,
a little bit of why?
A little bit of black.
That's it.
So you get.
Yeah,
and you don't know what it looks like if
you're watching like Avatar and a
beautiful four K tv and you're like all
the beautiful magical colors and wow,
you've never seen it before.
You're experiencing a muted connection
with your food and a very muted
connection with wildlife that sometimes
it's fucking uncomfortable and scary.
Yeah.
But it's also real.
It's bulk.
Yeah.
You know,
I've had some,
I've had some great hunts.
Marble Mountain wilderness up in
northern California.
Where's that?
What part?
This is just south of Oregon.
Oh yeah.
Where were you?
What'd you do up there?
A deer hunt killed a nice black tail
buck.
Was it like up there?
A mountains dense?
Yeah,
it's a timber.
It's great country.
Big,
big country.
I'm pretty rugged.
Yolie,
bullied wilderness.
Huge area.
Whereas that same area,
so little little,
uh,
um,
it's near
Marble Mountain wilderness.
Another giant area.
So many bear.
There's,
you almost seemed more bear than deer up
there.
Really [inaudible] why is that?
I don't know.
It's great habitat so you can go up
there and you can buy a deer tag and a
bear tag when I went there about 160
bucks for,
for non state resident or a non resident
of California out of state,
um,
hunter and a,
for a resident of California,
probably super cheap,
you know,
um,
but great hunting.
So you can go up there and hunt deer and
hunt bear.
Same same time.
A camp out.
Survive
sees the stars and their natural way.
Yeah.
All those things.
It opens up a,
like Megan mid August.
Well,
there's just an appreciation for this
strange planet when you.
You're viewing the lifeforms on it.
What does this Jamie picture at marble
mountain.
Wow.
God.
Damn.
That's beautiful.
So pretty.
Is that why it's called Marble Mountain?
Marble Mountain?
It looks like it's made out of marble.
Does look like raw marble.
Yeah.
Is it,
is it made out of marble?
Is that what the Rock is?
People go there to make countertops.
They're stealing from the land to make
someone's counter.
Yeah.
But isn't that amazing?
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
Um,
when I was in Montana this past week and
went to the yellowstone thing,
I mean,
you just be driving and you would just
drive and just look down the street and
go,
fuck,
this is crazy.
This place is crazy.
This,
this view is like,
um,
it's like a drug,
like you're taking in this incredible
mountain side covered in trees and the
sunlight is hitting the trees and it had
just got done raining and everything was
a vibrant and green and you're like,
this is a drug.
Like I'm getting an eyeball drug by
staring at this thing.
Like it's doing something to me
physically.
Will you just go,
wow.
It makes you feel good to see it.
Well,
when I'm at Marble Mountain Wilderness
district,
I mean that's public land.
Anybody can go there,
you can go there anytime you want.
And uh,
when I'm there,
what I feel like when.
So if you were at that exact same place
that,
that Jamie just had a picture of,
you feel small,
you feel the countries big,
you feel insignificant really compared
to how grand the country is.
And for me personally,
for,
I think for everybody,
it's good,
it's good to feel small.
Sometimes people elevate themselves,
people make themselves more important
than they really are.
That's a real.
I mean,
that puts you in check back there
because you realize if anything happens
back here,
does anybody even know.
I mean,
they'll find out,
but I'm just another not too much
different than an ant back here.
If I die,
nothing's going to change.
The wind's going still blow.
Um,
you know,
that lions are still going to try to
kill deer.
The elk are still going to try to breed
nothing changes.
So it's good.
I think it's good to have that feeling
every once in a while to realize,
know what?
I'm not that special.
Yes.
That's why I love the wilderness.
Well,
there's an inescapable understanding
when you're,
you're faced with the enormity of nature
is like everything to the left you
everything to the right and everything
as far as the eye can say.
He doesn't give a fuck.
And it's all been this way for who knows
how long.
And it will be this way for who knows
how long after you're gone.
This is just this life factory and it's
all going on all around you and it
doesn't care about you.
Now you were just an entrance.
You're an entrant in this weird sort of
a race that's going on where things are
trying to get by,
things just trying to get by,
by eating all the grasses the grasses
are trying to get by,
by producing some sort of a chemical
that discourages these things to eat
them.
The animals are trying to run from the
other animals that are trying to eat
them.
And,
and we're all just hanging out watching
or participating but in,
you know,
in regular life and everybody's so
worried about people's feelings and
people being,
um,
fairly treated or people,
whatever.
And it's just like,
it's,
it just gets.
So I get it.
I want,
you know,
everybody should be treated fairly.
But I like when it's just black and
white.
I like when I'm in the mountains,
I don't have to worry about or even
think about everybody's cause cause of
the day or I don't know.
I mean,
it's just,
it puts it in perspective,
it does put it in perspective and I
think it would be good for everybody,
including people that are really
invested in these causes to experience
this because I think it broadens your
perspective.
And again,
even if you're just hiking out there,
like I said,
my,
the hunt that made me feel the most
thankful was an unsuccessful one.
So while we were doing was hiking with
guns.
So we went hiking with guns for five
days in the rain.
Yeah.
And I came back and I felt so goddamn
good.
Yeah.
And not just good about like the ability
to have food,
um,
to not have to go out and hunt and kill
it because we were unsuccessful.
But that,
this is a,
this is a really cool thing that we
figured out how to do to escape that
world,
that world of harsh,
brutal nature that the tooth thing and
claw world.
But you're not going to appreciate that
unless you go in there and there.
Yeah.
That in there though,
that's where it gets hard.
It's hard to convince people like it's
hard to convince fat people to get off
the couch,
you know?
It's hard.
It's hard to convince people that it
probably would benefit them to be
uncomfortable.
Yeah,
that's.
We're addicted to comfort for sure.
You're addicted to being uncomfortable.
Just makes you real fucking weird.
Your captain uncomfortable.
That's your new name.
That's your podcast name.
Oh,
captain uncomfortable.
So let's talk about that because we're
gonna.
We're gonna end this soon and we're
going to start the first episode of the
Cameron Hanes podcasts,
but we have to have a name for it.
What did we come up with?
Keep hammering is a good one.
Yeah,
I liked that.
You know why?
Because that's the first thing that I
ever heard from you or about you.
I might even heard that before I met
you.
Yeah.
And I was like,
look at this fucking dude out there
working and his,
his,
his constant catchphrases.
Keep hammering.
It might.
Yeah.
That's a good thing to think of.
If you're thinking about quitting,
like if you think about every year even
like I'm going to run five miles a day
and then that third mile I'm like,
fuck,
I want to do this,
and you just say,
God fucking keep hammering.
Yeah.
I'm going to keep hammering.
The mindset of pushing yourself forward
is is a good mindset?
It's a good mindset to have because God
damn comfortable.
Soft das water balloon full of blood
body wants you to take breaks.
Yeah,
that bitch ass body does.
It's begging for a break bitch ass body.
We have.
What do you think,
Jamie?
Keep hammering.
Yeah,
that's sounds like a great one.
Or filthy skills.
Filtered skills as confusing though.
It's.
It's a little inside joke.
A little bit.
That's why might be better for a shirt.
It's like if I call this podcast,
let's get lucrative,
filthy sluts and go lots of ways.
Right?
So could be.
Could be grossly.
People think dirty porn,
right?
I think filled these skills might be
better as a shirt.
Okay,
so a hanes world,
like Wayne's world.
Somebody had one.
They made a poster right there.
I make an online thing,
so last week.
Yeah,
look,
but you need a sidekick.
Who would you be?
Would you be the Mike Myers or would you
be the Dana Carvey?
Garth.
He'd be good.
Wayne was Wayne.
Wayne,
Wayne and Garth was A.
Garth was Dana carvey.
Yeah.
Kinda like garth better.
You like garth better than the Wayne lot
better.
Well that's my boy.
I don't have a sidekick though.
You know you don't have a sidekick.
You just sidekick dude.
Who'd we get?
We need a.
You need a,
like someone to argue with you like some
vegan sort of nick tooth type character
to do battle with.
That's a whole different show.
I don't know,
but I'm just trying to like be in a
network.
I'm like a negative network network
executive.
Trying to fuck up your original idea.
We need.
We need drama.
We need a wacky neighbor.
You're showing you the gay neighbor
who's a Vegan.
Who gets mad at you,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It takes your meat out and he throws it
out in the outside and it goes bad to
punish you for killing animals.
Okay,
well that's,
that's episode one will have to put out
a feeler for that.
Just plenty of those dudes out there.
You can find them.
Just go through your instagram comments
and pluck them out.
You got to get them to come here from
Europe though.
Yeah,
well I know.
I know one guy who shared a picture of a
bear I killed on on his site and he
brought me a lot of hate mail.
Maybe he'd be my side kick.
There's a lot of those dudes.
Yeah,
there's a lot of those.
A lot of them are like Vegan
bodybuilders.
Just really interested.
That's the guy.
Yeah,
well there's a bunch of those steroid
users.
By the way.
Steroid users now does anything wrong
with steroids,
but you motherfuckers on talking about
that.
I see the size of your muscles.
I see your diet and that doesn't make
sense to me.
You're not taking in enough fat to
produce the kind of testosterone that
you need to develop those kinds of
muscles.
You're just not,
and you guys are lean as fuck in.
Your muscles are massive.
I see it.
I know what you're doing.
You're on dirt roads and by the way,
a lot of those steroids aren't the and
they require bacteria.
They were acquired dead life in order to
create.
Some of it's vague,
they actually make testosterone for wild
yams.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Right?
I didn't know that.
Um,
but uh,
either way you got this like some
hypocritical horseshit going on.
There's also a lot of like weird
posturing going on.
The part of the reason why they're doing
it is because they want to appear to be
very noble and it's what's called
Michael Sherman calls it a virtue.
Signaling Schermer is a very famous
skeptic and intellectual and uh,
he's like,
this is what they're doing.
Like there was signaling to the people
around them,
sort of like when an elk bugles is to
let all the other elk.
No,
he's a bad motherfucker.
I.
Well,
by having all these anti hunters,
which is a,
like you're gonna if you have an anti
hunter post,
you're absolutely going to have a bunch
of people to take your side.
Yeah.
Fuck those people.
Right.
But they also get to see how good your
six pack looks.
So you say fuck those people,
but you're also oil down and you're
talking about,
you know,
cruelty free,
awesome life and healthy living while
you're like overhead pressing a lot of
weight,
you look sleek and you probably get some
pussy that way and that's what these
guys are doing.
There's a lot of that going on.
It's not a coincidence that some of the
contest fucks are also some of the ones
who are the most into their physiques.
Right?
I see what you're doing.
I know what you're doing.
I guarantee you if you got those guys
alone with no one watching and he had a
conversation with them,
they would fall apart.
I guarantee you their arguments would
fall apart.
Their motivations would fall apart if
there's no one there to cheer them on or
help them.
He actually got to see them as a human
being.
Having a communication with you as a
human being about why it is that you're
spreading this kind of hate and then you
get into the very specifics of this and
you realize this argument is long and
vast and super complex.
You guys are trying to make it look like
it's not trying to make it look like you
eating that salad.
You're the best ever.
You're super awesome.
Yeah.
You're better than us as hunters.
Exactly.
That's why you're better than people who
don't do what you do.
Even though you just started doing it
four months ago.
Exactly.
So irritated.
Did you see the video of the dude who
was a eating a pizza?
It's got cheese in it and he fucking
freaks out.
He's a Vegan and he's talking about how
awesome it is to be Vegan and then
realizes in the middle of the video that
the,
the pizza has cheese and sauce with it
and he goes ballistic.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because there's a long video.
Oh,
and it's just.
He throws his phone.
He screamed and yelled.
He's so angry.
And in the,
in the video he's talking about like,
you can't say that you're a good person
if you're not vegan.
You can't say that you're a person who
tries to be a good person.
Well,
if that's the case,
why aren't you Vegan?
Like,
boy.
Well,
you fucking nailed it.
You made it so simple.
Yeah.
Well his mom ordered the pizza,
so it was just a misunderstanding.
It's very hilarious,
but this is a guy.
It's like we'd have to play this band
done.
Oh No,
I don't want to shit on this guy.
You can go find it if you want folks.
I don't want to play it or shit on this
guy.
He's just a young kid.
He's got his ideas and maybe in his mind
he's right,
but I just found the folly and watching
him freak out over some cheese.
I get it.
Cows or look,
man,
if you want something to be upset about
rather than hunters,
it is absolutely the fucking dairy
industry and agricultural gag laws.
These AG gag lungs that don't allow you
to film these chicken factories where
these things are stuffed into these
horrible conditions or pig factories or
factory farming.
I'm 100 percent with you.
I think it is one of the worst aspects
of civilization.
The way we acquire our protein and
here's,
here's another real problem and a
contradiction and for guys like you and
I,
we don't really have an argument against
this.
Not Everybody can hunt and if you want
to eat meat and you want to do it in an
ethical way,
you you have a real dilemma that they
are pointing out.
I think that by point,
by going against hunters though,
they're,
they're missing.
They're missing the mark in a big,
big,
big way.
You're missing the mark in a giant wet.
We're not the enemy.
No,
definitely.
But I mean if you do want to eat me and
you,
you don't hunt,
there are place.
I mean my buddy Adam La Roche owns a
three ranch and that's a free range.
Yeah,
you can do it.
It can be done,
but it's expensive and you're not going
to get it at Mcdonald's and it's.
If you want a quick cheeseburger and you
want to pull into that Wendy's drive
through,
boy,
you got to put those fucking those
ethical blinders on.
Yeah.
You have to.
Yup.
And they're in that sense.
Take a break from ethics that day.
Yep.
And in that sense,
all these vegans are right in that sense
when they're talking about how animals
are being treated,
where we're getting our milk from and
our cheese from it.
And in most of these large scale
factories,
they're there,
right?
They're 100 percent right?
And I'm with him.
I just think that this whole
conversation is really about human
beings and civilization itself and our
ability to diffuse responsibility,
our ability to detach ourselves and just
like we're talking about these people
that consume grain and don't think about
the consequences of life.
These people that consume all sorts of
vegetables that are used,
that pesticides are used,
that are killing off bs.
This is a huge issue that you contribute
to.
I do all,
all the,
all the people that we know that eat
fruits and vegetables most likely having
some way contributed to the large scale
death of a lot of different insects and
animals is just a part of being a
person.
And you can't deny that.
If you try to deny that and say,
well,
I'm trying to do the least harm
possible.
That's great.
That's like trying to say like,
I'm a serial killer,
but I only like to kill once a month.
I got this fucking guy argued with me
and one of the things he was arguing,
he's guy,
I'm 90 percent vegetarian.
Oh,
what does that me,
it's fucking ridiculous.
But that's the same thing.
That's the same thing as saying you're a
Vegan.
I am to six hours and I'm sleeping total
vegetarian.
So what is that?
That's 25 percent.
Yeah.
You're not eating at all during that
time?
No.
You're an Eriterian,
right?
So I'm like,
I'm better than him,
but if you can,
if you contributing to death,
then you really can't say anything and
everyone's contributing to death.
If you live in a house,
if your house was made out of wood,
if trees were fell to build your house,
animals died.
Do you know what Michael p dot?
Absolutely.
And their habitat was displaced.
And do you know what Michael Pollan
says?
He's the guy who wrote that book,
the Omnivore's dilemma.
Very,
very fascinating guy.
He said that they have done research
where they have played the sound of
animals eating leaves and plants next to
plants and somehow or another the very
sound of those animals eating plants
causes the plants to excrete defensive
chemicals.
So somehow or another,
these plants,
they're not just feeling that someone's
eating them,
they are hearing it and they're aware
and they're reacting to sound.
And so I'm sort of a strange way that is
commensurate with the way an animal
reacts to danger in some sort of a
strange way.
He also says that they produce some
human neurochemistry chemicals like
Serotonin and dopamine.
They,
they produce commensurate chemicals and
we don't know why.
We don't know what's going on.
Then.
Crazy fucking nuts,
nuts.
Um,
I had to read it like three or four
times.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
They played sounds of animals eating
plants next to the plants and the plants
are.
That's actually a pretty barbaric to do
that.
It's rude.
Yeah.
Either one,
don't eat them.
Don't torture them.
First it's like,
you know,
you wouldn't kill cows,
but before you kill them,
you play this horrible sound.
Yeah.
Other cows getting killed?
The bad news for Vegetarians,
plants can hear themselves being eaten
and become defensive.
When attached attacked researchers from
the University of Missouri found plants
respond to attack.
They discovered that the sound of
caterpillars eating made them more
defensive and plants that heard
caterpillar sounds released more mustard
oils which are unappealing to
caterpillars and thus ward them off.
Wow,
wow.
But plants that heard the wind,
despite having similar acoustic sound,
knew not to waste their defensive
capabilities.
Although this suggests that plants are
able to identify sounds in their
environment.
That makes sense,
man.
Most people don't give it a second
thought when they're tucking into a
plate of salad,
but perhaps we should be a bit more
considerate when chomping on lettuce.
Now,
scientists have found that plants
actually respond defensively.
You just need to accept the fact that
life eats life.
Life eats life is to it.
Well,
that doesn't allow you to be
sanctimonious or,
or to take the moral high ground.
So I'm going to have to say you're full
of shit in a piece of fucking human
garbage and you're out there raping the
world with your filthy skills.
By the way,
you can get this filthy skills,
tee skills with a z.
like the young kids are doing these
crazy kids.
Cameron hanes.com.
Right?
That's it.
Free Shipping.
Felt skills.
Bitches.
All right,
we're going to come back in this time.
Cam's going to do all the talking
because I can't,
I can't.
I can't shut the fuck up too much
coffee.
And uh,
we're going to come back with a cameron
hanes podcast at.
Won't be on Youtube.
Maybe he'll eventually get it set up
where it's going to be on youtube,
but I'll tweet it,
he'll tweet it,
will put it on facebook and everything
like that.
And you'll be able to download that
shit.
Friends and neighbors campaigns.
I love you buddy.
You're awesome.
Thank you.
Alright.
See you people.